le caire 14 donc fab on n'a pas fait le
pré stream
aujourd'hui parce que malheureusement
allé manger voilà c'était très bon c'est
très bon et ça que tu pars ce soir donc
on avait envie d'un peu profité d'un peu
discuté après c'est vrai que c'est quand
même une journée extraordinaire un des
matches vraiment là tu te dis hype total
et hype et de ouf
il ya quand même du saumon il ya la
vodka tkm extraordinaire en terme de
spectacle un événement dans c'est quoi
comme ça ne va t'il se qualifier pour
les candidats que carlson va se
qualifier donc bon quoi alors est-ce que
s'il perd le match du cou qui perd là et
qui perd le match sur caïman dufour et
ne pas se retrouver
c'est terrible je sais pas donc ce n'est
pas sûr on se dit bon faut bien gagner
la coupe du monde pour être sûr fait
bien sûr voilà j'espère qu'on va être
bien sûr tant que en train de vérifier
que tout marche bien au passage donc fab
j'attends que les gens arrivent on s'est
pas ouvert le bond de chaque
aujourd'hui quand on avait un autre à
notre patte et on sait qu'on aura
peut-être moins de monde n'a pas fait le
pré la rive mais bon après comme ça les
rend les lampions à quoi les passionnés
hardcore on va dire hayato j'ai requis
dix à lui sa lutte au giro yakine
schaars explo c'est un pas de près la
ftq investit accueillir les gens
pensaient que le prélat il était
beaucoup mieux que le live terrible
modère les gens partent 1 on est tous
les jours ce parent direct
c'était beaucoup mieux quand il y avait
l'écran noir
bon bah écoute on va attendre
j'espère très honnêtement qu'on aura un
meilleur spectacle pierre parce que
honnêtement on s'est fait chier
hier ouais c'était long il s'est pas
passé grand chose après ce que je
faisais c'était une belle partie en soi
parce que tout a vraiment bien calculé
bien défendu mais après c'est pas des
partis qui sont belles à regarder c'est
plus des parties intéressantes force
mortelle avait le tour c'est 8 bravo
bravo voilà may hamm et s'était pas
forcément un truc pour passer quatre
heures et demie dessus quoi
après mais après j'ai eu en terme de jeu
les joueurs ont vraiment bien c'est une
belle partie quoi mais c'était pas une
partie spectaculaire on va dire ça comme
ça
yes et voilà donc il ya elles ont fait
nul juste pour dire le contexte dans
l'autre match entre les russes cariat
qui ne fait de ses affiliés nul donc là
aussi ça peut jouer la qualif
encadraient déjà décisif puis bon si nul
départager voilà quoi aujourd'hui on
peut peut-être avoir la chance de donner
le rapide c'est possible ce que cariat
qui il avait fait contre maxime
mais alors il peut peut-être faire qui
sait et duda karl scène duda peut se
faire sécher dans l'ouverture mais c'est
passé comme ça ne va chercher à sécher
ou avoir un truc qui jouent sont trop de
risques
filali noir quand même oui on va voir un
bouddha nous donne des quatre peut-être
cas on sait pas des cartes sûrement avec
quelqu'un que j'ai déjà envoyé le chat 1
milliard on l'a fait plusieurs fois
quand même hein comme il se passait rien
sur deux stations journée est là qu
enfin il remet bien sa veste
il a émis un pion sur la quatrième
rangée quatre gros durs avoir un nous on
à l'écran petit 20 pions qui est parti
mon fab est peut-être sur la case 400 il
ne veut pas voir ce à quoi bien
m'hydrater avant le concours de marie
lajus qu'il a déjà 12 on ne sait pas on
ne sait pas se toucher puis à savourer
attention surtout que j'aurais acheté
mais en vrai mais sur l a6 est pas si
grave
7 h 6 pire non je suis bien à 6 très
intéressant christian bauer 6 mille
marines ouais on va aux 4,5
il n'y a plus rien à savoir c'est déjà
égal c'était déjà séché d'après vlad
il n'y a rien à savoir j'étais très
frustré pendant ce tournoi de du de
l'énorme décalage de l'échiquier de
chasse comme la mitre la caméra et le
truc c'est une espagnole mais bon à
chaque fois que je le dis oui non et
c'est très très bien bon ben c'est mieux
qu'il dégage
non que le truc est très pratique c'est
vraiment très bien quand tu stream alors
qu'avant il y avait beaucoup moins de
décalage
beaucoup plus vite c'était beaucoup
mieux et disons beaucoup mieux c'est
mieux mais alors j'arrive pas à
comprendre pourquoi c'est mieux ah ça
bug ça décale jeu parce qu'il ya de
mieux en fait mais on m'a dit que
c'était beaucoup mieux bon on m'a dit
détrompe toi à moi je me trouve quoi on
sait à petit espagnol f6 classique on
imagine que nous d'avoir ok tu penses
que tu as dragon ball ce serait qui ce
combat c'est du rhin ouais en garde
scène ce qu'on peut le voir comme au
bout est ce que l'agencé beaux quartiers
bour et bien glace de trunks coin fut
inaugurée dès c'est très dur pour lui
connaît cette psychologie mais piccolo
ici c'est picoler à se faire défoncer
quoi ouais mais luna il est un peu jeune
tapie que l'eau c'est un peu un ancien
ça sert à rien de regarder on peut
éteindre tout de suite en raffy colo
maintenant il va enlever son petit truc
pour être beaucoup plus léger c'est beau
écrivait un contre freezer
c'est un peu sa revue c'est vraiment ce
qu'on parlait de piccolo tout à l'heure
mais c'est vrai qu'à chaque fois était
tellement motivés pour tous ces
combattants l'impression que vous il
arrive il va il va arranger le sort de
l'humanité pierre je suis fait défoncer
quoi fins il joue le coup de buzz qui à
4,12 à oreille ou si tu leur fais un
petit fou bessette b4 pour changer
on va voir cela prête
ben qu'ils puissent pas sympa ça pour
rien mais vlad c'est clairement tortue
géniale
là c'est très très cher que ces tortues
génial je me bats plus groupe d'états je
suis beaucoup trop forts pour ça tout ça
c'est de regarder la vidéo très
intéressante hier de la morale des saïan
sur végétaux on a tout écrit parfois de
nietzsche ouais c'est un surhomme
dragonball quoi mais c'est vrai que carl
scène c'est un personnage assez puissant
mais je pense que c'est un méchant je
sais pas pourquoi ça peut pas être un
gentil en fait ouais c'est un saumon
quoi enfin tu vas devenir gentil le jour
où un autre sort car ils vont là du goût
du frij et à un allez peut-être carlson
cvg tard en fait du début quoi mais du
début mai après devient gentil
en fait c'est juste bas qui s'est
déguisée pour le magnat du coup
s'éteignent shinhan très dur mais bon je
vais essayer que je connais moins bien
que toi je crois que les principaux
dragon ball z
dragon ball est fêtée veut faire un tout
nouveau qu'il est là bon ok tu veux fais
ci fais ça
si tout le monde oui bon d'accord pas
quoi d'autre puis voilà il se marre et
après les dragon ball sont par de
partout et près tu suis allé retrouver
quoi mais je veux dire il pouvait pas se
battre non historien vers un moment il a
sué quoi avait tombé vite il change de
coûts ellis a fait dragon ball gt à les
dragons cgt je respecte pas je m'arrête
dragon ball z - beaucoup pas avec le
petit au bout je crois dans les trucs
en fait c'est la réincarnation enfin il
sent qu'il doit bien le tas il passe
dans la transmission beaucoup il veut le
fort mais quoi ne prononcez pas d'acquis
ségo c'est pas dur à dire je ne sais pas
ce sont des absences dans votre tête
nicolas les actifs et fulgurances
il enlève son truc il est trés figurants
absence of death ray beaucoup absence
juste défoncer pour le mans ça répète
non mais il n'avait pas vu tous mes
potes comme come back in ouais j'ai
passé une bonne idée je vais l'espagnol
contre banyuls les banques issues peut
faire notre côté important facile quoi
enfin
c'est toi crient les bons je crois pas
que je suis un yann chaque enfin fait
rien je vais que musharraf
partout ils sont très chiant georgina
twitch attend 2 points à 106 morts il
fait très chaud avec les docteurs
machine à céder ses potes de végéta puis
même les potes de freezer après ils ont
le petit truc mais j'ai pas regardé
assez attentivement waouh il ya donc on
ya très longtemps mais je l'aimé bien
avec l'afrique
mais si borde basse et le jeu des
cyborgs en fait j'avais des stockfisch
qui viennent le voir aussi qui sait en
fait il était membre du bien d'un to
grow très chiant qui te bouffe ton
énergie et beaucoup il s'agit suis à
fond et ça va se faire défoncer par vg
d'arafat finalement le professeur je
sais pas quoi bon lui aussi se fait
défoncer m'apprête à passer 18 s'est dit
saleh l'autre aussi le punk mais bon ils
sont en fait ils sont bouffés par celle
qu'elle devient très très fort on va
voir les gapençais théorie on avait déjà
tout expliqué contrebas qui le coup avec
1,4 c'est une anti anti marshall et a du
coup tours veille son protégé le pion tu
veux refaire c'est parce qu'ils veulent
est ce que vous voulez refaire
l'ouverture va bien on va demander un
on a un peu en roue libre les gars
assurera cette forme tournoi après c'est
aussi normal on n'a plus trop de joueurs
et puis bon on se pose des questions
comme existentielle cornetto c'est notre
caillou pas mal en fait je suis entre
dragon ball le fait je suis beaucoup
plus au regard des interrupteurs ou tout
au moins
enfin plus même stream est moins
mainstream à la fois en fait parce que
là on le sait très vieux adversaires
ouais bon alors juste pour vous dire un
1ce position sa version classique
l'espagnol donc le plan de base dans le
monde et blanc il adore prendre le
centre faire ces trois des quatre c3
pour faire ça évidemment les noirs ils
peuvent juste faire dès 6 ans 10 ans qui
fait des quatre je vais te crever le
cavalier est donc grosse pression sur le
centre les blancs doivent réagir souvent
fermé et c'est donc sa raison pour
laquelle les blindes bien faire h3 en
prévention et là il ya plein de bosses
mais noir soit faire cavalier à saint
cloud figurines mon lit des 100 jeunes
cavaliers pour mettre l'option est un
peu renforcé le centre soit partir la
bande des huit membres et fière histoire
de venir renforcer le pion de 5
et puis garder le fou qui peut être
ouvert ici peut-être c5 un jour avoir ok
il ya toutes ces possibilités mais
surtout comme une ombre de chasse pions
il se garde l'option de faire des cinq
donc ces salons mais marchal dit l'autre
jour et l'idée oui mais c'est que
surpris on croit en cavalier prend donc
les notaires d'options mais bon ils vont
défendre leurs cavaliers ils vont
dégager la tour genre sa tour par la
dame elle fallait d'abord h4 est menacée
m'a donc soit on fait j'ai trois pour
éviter il vient et en fait il se fou qui
va se développer il peut nous pousser
les pions ils vont ramer l'autre tour
ici donc voiron tech développement des
noirs ça donne pas mal de compensation
donc le coup choisi dans la partie par
par duda restait le cook etienne avait
joué aussi donc c'est passé 3 qui est le
grand coup mais qui peut se heurtaient
n'ont qu'à se se marche à l'amour après
c'est comme ça c'est à quatre bombes à
l'idée c'est que ça fait de menaces en
fait on peut prendre vu que le pion là
est cloué problème donc les noirs
doivent faire quelque chose comme baky
carlson avait jeu le fouler cette belle
idée c'est que si on prend puis on prend
balla touré plus qu'ils ont prise il ya
un autre couple ont du coup les
comprennent pas quand c'est comme ça il
faut plutôt des 3es sorte le cavalier
la partie de baky c'était ça le rend fou
des deux élus dame 17
c'était c'était ce truc je dis pas
n'importe quoi il avait fait des cinq
vont sacrifier un pion et c'est ok ça
c'est ce qu'il avait fait qu'on bâtit
magnus alors soit il ya un truc qui lui
allait pas où il a peur de la modération
je sais pas bon toujours est il il a
choisi de tourbe et 8 est donc la
troisième motion qui l'a pas fait ni
l'autre fois ni aujourd'hui ça serait b4
injustes ont interdit la prise sur quoi
il ya des quatre possibles ou d'autres
cours du mois vous pouvez tout retrouvez
toutes les analyses sur la structure
youtube avec l'analyse de la partie
détiennent pour ceux qui veulent
approfondir un complètement le fou
bessette et la prépa dans la partie
précédente vous pouvez aller à vous
pouvez aller voir et donc tourbe et 8
c'est plutôt un bon choix fab dans un
tournoi de changer un tu changes comme
ça tu sais pas attrapé alors bon après
j'espère pour dudek celui-là révisé
parce qu' un pas qu'il est naïf à croire
nivard jeu tous pareils djoko joue 43e
coup et moi je vais faire comme si cette
enfin évidemment qu'il faut regarder
autre chose
tao fallait regarder b4 fallait regarder
tomber huit ferrari phobos est dans
cette position est donc tombé 8
pourquoi pas pinon me dis que ça va trop
vite trop vite l'explosion badauds mais
je pensais juste exprès de pas trop mais
justement c'est pour ça que comme comme
jo et que t'as faim tu aller vite non tu
vas tu vas à une vitesse normale par
rapport au fait qu'on suit du direct
mais c'était pour dire si vous voulez
aller et revoir on a tous bien d'avoir
déjà dans une vidéo donc vous pouvez
revoir à votre rythme n'y a pas de y'a
pas de soucis quoi ça a déjà été fait
c'est pour ça que me permettait de de le
dire surtout que là il va pas se passer
grand chose dans les minutes à venir là
il vient de jouer à ce trop joué par
manu se rasseoir donc demandé une autre
il a fait un bond grande marche t on a
bien vu juste et l'hydrater avant alors
vous êtes plutôt pour 12,1 pour carlson
team saumon ou team votre vote ya donc
ça va être une sorte de marshall avec à
quatre buts inclus alors ça change
souvent beaucoup de choses mais faut
réfléchir
enfin je peux même pas vous dire
exactement et du saumon il ya de la
vodka travaux qui en est qu avec charles
ah bon georges corm pour baky c'est du
50 50
on va faire un petit straw poll on peut
faire la hâte en la retenant leur
demandent de leur pourcentage de live
sur ce match alors ils sont arrivés à
quel level j'aurais jambes pour cent en
pourcentage
avec 50 % 80 % 90 20 02 - 261% 10%
important depuis que le président lula
est plus rock 1 28% 75% et où on s'en
fout en fait 0% 8% 1 sur 10 et carlson
étude est atteint ses intentions des
finales très envie de commenter jusqu'à
400 kg on voit le travail très très hype
et voilà c'est les gens qui sont venus
un ouais mais c'est même pas parmi les
gens qui sont pas basés 5% c'est 5 022
si je peux être très précis c'est ça me
rappelle un commentaire qui avait eu sur
la chaîne youtube d'un mec on avait
écrit il ya les verrai ce live c'est un
mélange entre une gay pride incarné sous
tipi bref c'était vraiment de la mer de
ce1
j'avais adoré quoi vous disant que
c'était fait ajourner ses joueurs en
leur disant apprécier encore
bref c'est à leur génial comme phrase
c'est le même calibre avons regardé il
vraiment bien sûr que c'était de la
merde j'ai regardé jusqu'au bout c'est
vraiment nul 16 ans que je vais dans
cette boîte je peux te dire nuls mais
moi un pastis sirop d'orgeat mais enlève
le sirop d'orgeat c'est ça qui m'a fait
mal à ses bons toit de verre il est venu
juste pour qu'on parle en arrière fond
vanté le travail puisqu'elle serait
important forum carac scène comme un
méchant juste parce qu'il est très fort
mais en fait c'est un méchant pas parce
que tu avais en végétal
bon bah c'est votre
très humain après tout les maronites
reste qu'un peu de freud oui freud harry
le moelleux sûrement vrai mais c'est
beaucoup ce concept de surmoi seria un
mois bon il est là ayant moi qui ai cave
au dessus sur mon il n'y a pas un sur
sur moi et je pense qu'il ya un fait à
le sûrement ils pensent décidé là c'est
le bien c'est le match il croit et d'un
autre nous toi tu crois pouvoir décider
mais en fait moi je suis bien je suis
encore là paillasson le pastis en face
en argent et le bazooka mandarine c'est
quoi j'aime bien mais si jamais le nom
du surnom en fait ouais c'est vrai le
seul ça c'est sans fête soit tu prends
une décision était qu'on en fait
car si en moi c'est lui la vraie vie
c'est vraiment le cas ça veut dire
calais promotion a priori sinon qu'on a
envie de faire la paix après ce qu'ont
fait passer à d'abord mais là le fou il
va peut-être en baisse est dans
certaines variantes contrairement bah en
fait c'est ce que je me
dil qu'est ce que c'est hyper tuerie
qu'on l'a déjà vu qu'est-ce qu'on va
singer déjà vu sur la c6 le coup hamas
alors c'est un truc normal met intercalé
ça laisse un si petit si mal pour le
mans vient on regarde d'ouverture rires
le géant cheat codes
mettez-moi de mona lisa avec moi très
important je connais qui cheat codes
pour la crypte homme est témoin de mona
lisa en vantant un kiev 6 août et 6ème
c6 je sais pas je sens que ça va être
une version pour les blancs mais je suis
sûr que l'on a déjà fait une vidéo sur
un truc comme ça des cadres est et
peut-être ça des six la tour se barre
d'ovono se bat et là du coup on ne sait
pas et g4 il joue peut-être on va avoir
en tout cas ça joue bien que toi qui as
on annonce tout le monde sait pas mais à
tout moment je lui si la turbine est
ainsi qui par quoi voilà c'est beaucoup
mieux non là n'est que toi
en plus elle est les gens étaient très
heureuses que c'est un modèle leopard
mais la partie c'est en effet son mari
feraient des fessés 6 mais oui c'est un
modèle logo je fais ça ouais mais ça
rottal 95 des options et c'est très
heureux 95 des lits l'avons fait c'est
si ce n'est pas fait qu'il ya c'est
d'être une nouveauté enfin non vote mais
[Musique]
on va les vérifier maintenant forcément
un très bon modèle quoi c'est beau quand
ils vont envoyer ils ont pas du tout
pensé que ça pouvait faire la dhimma
giner qui arrive vraiment un très bonne
ambiance et kevin parent
e
ouais on s'est toujours théorie théo
rien
mais pas trop en fait théorie net j'ai
envie de dire en fait c'est la fameuse
position du granby marshall ça deviendra
un pion là une tour l'un pions la cua et
blanc des fois ils aiment bien faire à 4
justement pour voir cette tour
donc je me questionne et j'imagine que
détroit doit être un coup des cadres
doit être un coup à jouer à votre jeu
mais ils peuvent
car longtemps mandat pour se dire dans
mon qu'elle va remonter une nuance que
ça peut changer
l'autre truc à dire c'est comme on a un
cul tour de 8 dinars seront ses toiles à
la 8
on peut se dire il a peut-être perdu
attendant tous remis depuis tours 8
offerte en direct par la banque
huawei en fait la personne qui vous
savez ce que je pense à ces six et
l'autre ainsi fait passer 6 mais je sais
que ça met plus de game et je sais pas
s'il y avait des bons notamment voit
donc c'est un truc assez nouveau kivu
carlson ça je sais pas a priori j'aime
pas ce qu'il fait mais comme il est
beaucoup mieux préparé
faut croire ça va mais j'aurai une
partie contre contre quelqu'un et kim
tout ça je me dirai stop est terrible
mais d'ailleurs peut-être salem et
freiner avec l'ordi mais un cap il ya
déjà très peu de parties après ces trois
donc en vrai et permet à bab ses trois
passages où tu attends mais vite hockey
j'assume troisième coup mais abbey a b c
3 c'est peut-être normal quoi ouais et
nous vous servirons et non s'il fait des
cinq indiqué des cinq bien quand même
très peu de parties ont fait des dessins
qui d'autre a fait tomber 8 milliard
mais ok on va dire qu'arsène checker ça
et alors vous prendre des cinq non non
il ya caruana qui a joué c'est en 2019
donc attention contre europe sonne
robson avait fait des 3 après l'ag non
non non bien avant la wii wheel se
trouve donc en vrai et abarth marais à
parfum qui avait répondu sup i am et
c'est sur un sur un bestiau mondiaux
fondée en poche il ya tellement peu de
celles trouvées 8 qui est rare earth et
la partie de supplice arrêta très bon
directeur sportif mais a ouais je sais
tu imagines série qui s'appelle l'ombre
ouais ombre je veux marshall ont de mar
chan marshall on l'a avec marchal trombe
[Rires]
ce courant ce qui comme on peut hein ça
dit quand on va voir un peu les russes
c'est déjà fini
alors non ils n'ont pas déjà fait nul
c'est une route ouverte de l'espagnol on
se repasse les coûts s'il voulait c'est
cariat kim blanc contre fait dossier met
en avant j'aime bien donc espagnole un
peu pareil quoi sauf que là on part
qu'il prend 4,1 manquera pas du tout
[ __ ] j'ai cru qu'ils avaient fait ça
mais après ça ressemble et trompe toile
avaient détrôné alors c est spécial
fougue et cette auto proclamé
spécialiste de l'espagnol fab libye mais
attention les graves en fait la position
mais l'un dans l'autre à la structure et
du coup karekin la pendule qui se veut
plus que c'est notre ami fidèle dans mes
soeurs sont beaucoup m comment qu'il
détrompe toi en anglais unmiss taken
yourself
ces bombes dans plusieurs salons de
forêt du siège france fingen repense à
autre chose moreau diction ventilation
don't lose yourself on te dire d'être un
pion m'économise take that don't ever 24
me wrong side il valide à indiana j'ai
fini un peu moins techno notice
ah ouais
masques ce casque grand dessein que moi
j'aime pas trop fait c'est un coup tu
pourras toujours faire plus tard mais si
tu peux garder ta perte de foudre a
inventé compte en échec au match aller
de magnus pour mancka mme seillé nul en
fait donc là c'est les matches retour et
cela aussi nul n'y a rien eu que des
nuls donc voilà ça c'est deux
demi-finales et aujourd'hui ma match
retour pour le public c'est plus bas
vous plaint que la provine peut-être que
je vais me des trompes emea
le film que genk kevin je pense oui car
on l'a pour magnus sarron magnus magnus
magnus quoi sert il ya un match enfin
l'argentine il ya une semaine de chèques
à l'ordre de foot va de fouet entre
l'équipe de colons qui chauffe contre
l'anus biannuel très heureux en fait je
sais pas comment ça s'est fini 00 le
classique
et puis qu'est là pour fabre et j'ai pas
si le sol on se noie dans la vodka ou le
saumon bois la vodka un moment il vomit
quoi petit prend pour la finale féminine
diané soir bourgoin chez nos rues après
tant qu'il ya de la vie il ya de
l'espoir
après y'a aucun enjeu non mais bon je
pense c'est bien pour que c'est nous que
c'est bien je serai heureux et puis aval
ce vote est un témoin je peux faire
rêver les études après le travail font
rien pour eux contents pour elle quoi
elle travaille plus que tout la fin des
exercices de chambre l'affairé est sur
sa garde à fond un service qui a
rassemblé 5 4
la main froide j'aime pas non mais
d3 et d4 en fait il va réfléchir pour
comprendre les nuances
parce que dans le marshall normal les
deux sont possibles et 3 et mieux non
aujourd'hui théoriquement mais bon la
police où était vrai on est comme l'ail
pourquoi aucun enjeu en finale filles
nine alors c'est simple rapide stream
c'est qu'en fait c'est le même truc que
pour les hommes c'est un temps un
qualificatif aux candidats et les deux
sont déjà
enfin un gage déjà qualifié causé nuque
elle vient de se qualifier donc va être
l'enjeu du temps à féminin on n'est pas
dans la finale qui en a aucun mais dans
le match pour la troisième place qui est
une fille qui sera repêché entre tenait
mieux tout choc way qui va tenir
donc en fait le vrai enjeu c'est pour le
match de la troisième place
après gagner ben tu gagnes tu t'attends
à des comptes en tuning sur ton palmarès
- oui mais ça ça mais ça bat but ultime
en fait je dois dire que pour guerrier
qui n'a de se qualifier dans le
championnat de russie sommes là je me
dis rome parce que c'est l'appellation
russe très important de bien faire la
différenciation pour les russes en fait
c'est un drame et on ma femme c'est ya
pas de mix en fait - le mixte n'existe
pas en russie donc bon je vais
traduction littérale guerrière qui na
s'est qualifiée dans le championnat de
la super finale du championnat de russie
hommes ce qui est en soi un vrai exploit
c'est je crois que c'est la première à
réussir cet exploit
donc on en fait gagner à zilina sas a
beaucoup plus de valeur que gagner une
coupe du monde féminine qui enfin notre
un qualificatif était déjà qualifié
comparativement la fed et 4 fautes en
toi tu penses pas je sais pas en fait ce
que je pense me
[Musique]
non juste un tournoi comme ça dans votre
en fait mais c'est pas si important de
gagner moins mais peut-être plus pour
kosteniuk justement oui ça pourrait au
final je pense qu'elles échangent un
podium dans le championnat de russie 1
contre une coupe du monde
ben oui même une cinquième place
même une qualification juste je mens
qualification déjà eu beau que bon a
priori car le ça doit faire 100 des
sites son prochain coup c'est le coût
auquel on s'attend à moins nantis une
autre idée étonnante ces gars je ne
savais qu'elle quoi et pour la huitième
place qualificative au gp fidh et chez
les hommes comment elle est décernée
balle retournera au vélo robe bi c'est
pour ça que pour maxime
ce sera très important de bien performer
la think we alors là c'est on va
vraiment en fait très important enfin
bon sens rendais pas compte de base mais
en fait c est un choix déterminant
maxime a besoin de regagner des places
au classement pour aller au grand prix
fidh donc très important de bien jouer a
prouvé être en restant là ça pourrait
aller mais faut pas descendre trop enfin
la remontée serait bien mais ouais ouais
sera très important il offre un très
important et puis après on aura ce match
de championnat du monde ira le lac ou de
le championnat d'europe par pays aussi
très important aussi pour le lot pour le
vélo et pour l'équipe de france donc en
fait il ya beaucoup tournant important
là qui arrivent mais à la cyclo fiscale
sera vraiment important que maxime et
puis on va pouvoir jauger ses absences
les fulgurances et ses présences et ses
présences sur l'a4 à kehl oui si tu sais
que tu as sir fait un mauvais temps là
ça va quand même recasser la dynamique
d'insertion coupe du monde et c'est donc
c'est un toit vraiment déterminant à mon
avis pour la suite pour maxime tokyo
sociales des diffuseurs busters à ses
abords mais là on détermine dans la
gauche tournoi mais c'est pas le bien
c'est quoi ce jeu à la con mais c'est
bon gars ça serait mon gars ça que j'ai
pas joué mon gosse moi jamais moi je
veux une partie de nos votes par maxime
du coup
quand j'écris j'écris un petit truc je
te laisse ça me plaît je me
laffont 4 federica des bombes à
quinssaines réfléchit à fond comme je
vous dis j'imagine qu'il va faire food
et 6 fautes j'ai du mal à maintenir son
visage à notre cou mais je peux vous
dire ce que dit la turbine est faux des
six coups principal de lardy
après te parle de dams et 7 et de tourbe
et 7 comme coup trop subtil pour moi
tour b sat on va dire food et le
fouillis sérologique chasselas tour pour
passer la dame et je commets marshall
met donc à un moment ou un autre
personne d'avoir une idée de faire un
truc à 7 tours v8 envoyé un bébé cas de
faire un petit justement tourbe et 7
pour je sais pas quoi alors certes ou
quoi mais en bétonnant bien dames c'est
cette sale tour et puis non vraiment au
plus tôt
à tanger pas ouvrière lo ce que tu dis
faites dams et 7
pourquoi pas en fait tu veux aligner un
peu pour aller là-bas mais normalement
c'est mettre le foulard et la dame labat
est plus offensif fut créé plus de neuf
heures loin après damas et sept
peut-être jouable à peu près mais c'est
quoi adidas est encore grande marche
très bien il a fait des cas très
concrets marche à fond quoi et c'est
beau quoi car elle s'est même offert le
la prépa des quatre je ne connais plus
tu mens savons qu'il faut à detroit et
tu sais ce que je suis en train de me
dire notre hall ce nom n'est pas
vraiment notre nom mais notre hall
sérieusement nîmois basse j'écoute est
tout ouïe
je suis tout ouïe duda il avait battu
magnus dans une position hyper à
tactique
oui dans la partie c'était qu'elle
tourne en as été un tournant il jouait
super mal
oui de questions dernier bakar et
refaire ya près de 20 ans après c'était
en novembre ce ténor ouais ouais j'sais
pas seulement vrai ou c'est n'importe
quoi et c'est norwich s à
et du coup parti très bordélique très
tactique magnus qu'ils attaquent à fond
il avait défendu avait battu hier bah je
t'ai remontrer lappartient il voit le
torse et bien en avance magnifie la hat
tiens je suis gagnant rebonds bon enfin
le mec qui l'est plus c'est beau il mais
48 a calculé le tracé est vraiment de la
merde vent debout ce coup pour sa lutte
à la fin un very easy bon il leva et là
du coup car le scène il sentait un peu à
jouer mes gars tactique contre duda pour
une bonne dans son aide mais en fait ce
serait beaucoup doit lui faire une
nouvelle fois une qu'ils calculent très
mal car le sel vraiment très faible
comment peut-il jouer des coups aussi
quand précis très bon vu cela qu'il est
bluffé bon j'étais complètement préparé
jeter tous jusqu'au 25e
on s'attend à ça du coup à tout ça pour
dire que ça veut dire quoi en fait j'en
ai eu dans ma pensée
non tout ça pour dire que c'est
peut-être une position intéressante pour
duda ouais bon après y'a un jour du jeu
pour magnus il a mûri gamba qui je veux
bien passer un truc c'est pas tout à
fait pareil à maxime qui confirme
jacques écrit clairement non ce grand
suisse n'a absolument aucun intérêt
mais comparé à la sicafi cap ah bah oui
beaucoup moins ce qui compte c'est monté
des points bloquants fin cette rame
entrait dans portes en mai
on va trouver dans les vagues mais ça me
fait penser d'être un péché d'orgueil 6
a ainsi fait ça pour ça je veux dire
rogers a vraiment fait il voulait dit
qu'elle aimait que dans sa filière oui
oui vous les montre et je suis plus fort
parti cours justement des photos issues
de faire ça bon je parle plus jeunes
avant ici oui tiens je vous invite à
voir si de temps en temps je m'écarte
scène je sais pas si c'est ça qui pend
facile pense ça c'est une erreur mais
non mais peut-être juste qu'ils entrent
sur le tournage disons il fait que 4,5
j'ai l'impression qu'il a il a préparé
ça pour ce tournoi
peut-être de longue date jeudi rob
marshall et il a depuis belle lurette
priori mais il a listé qui jaurès à ici
et ce type d'opposition qui la
regardaient comme quand il avait préparé
un fonds sachets sneaker fait qu'il ait
son type de position qui jouait un peu
tout le temps donc pense ça serait une
avancée avec les blancs effraie un peu
pareil quoi et on dit j'aimerais bien
avoir une revanche et manuscrits qui
n'est moi aussi j'espère vraiment une
victoire de double à effet de serre pour
avoir la revanche sa petite robe rose je
suis complètement d'accord avec kiev
pirlo moi aussi j'aimerais bien voir
cette revanche qui perd l'autre perd
aussi bon c'est le prix qu'a offert
carlson karekin revanche comme ça non
mais revanche ott n'ont pu serait le
match change puisque carrière qui une
fois et pour une place des candidats car
cette façon lui je pourrions début donc
troisième classe pour lui bon très
important tiens qui doit pour rien
karine beaucoup d'enjeu du coup pour les
prénoms mais carey king il veut vraiment
la médaille de bronze dans ce tournoi
comme karen o quoi comme carey augusta
mais oui du coup car ils ignoraient pour
rien mais ça nous assurerait fedoseyev
et duda aux candidats et c'est beau
d'avoir fait de cfa à vrai dire un match
pour la troisième place feydeau cf car
c'est là
sortie tellement dégoûté web après une
finale à regarder mon fort sinon mais
voilà pour karl scène j'étais venu là où
un mec du top 20 mondial
un seul nom il y en a comme je bâtis
quoi ouais ça va remonter à lyon il a
éliminé d'éliminer après un match
parfait mais presque honteux fedoseyev
facile bas aussi longtemps que tu fais
comme djoko en fait mais voit ses
chances contre carl scène on est encore
bon pour un an avec magnus non il a ses
chances pour moi non mais enfin il a ses
chances mais magnus est favori quoi
ouais mais il y aura du poutine non mais
on sait jamais en fait disons depuis
lens - l'annoncé je t'ai bien sûr qu'il
ait dit fonséca liquide mais dans un
groupe punch dans un bain de sang ouais
mais tellement eu match en fait c'était
chaud que du coup jose - faire des
pronostics tranché c'est la seule fois
où on va dire le match va être serré non
je dis pas que c'est la première fois
aussi le match peut être serré le mec
qui va se prendre plus qu'à ça peut
aussi en fait ce n'est pas une turbo
ouais hein et pour moi en fait garçonnet
média favori en fait mais
at il le serait un peu qu'on importe qui
de façon sûre ce problème enfin problème
ou pas il est plus fort et mais voilà
non mais de base c'est pas on n'est sûr
de rien ni pauvres il fait un bon début
où il se prépare bien attendre il a
progressé il joue pas mal se prépare
bien machin on vient après notre hall le
quart yakine qu'on voit en ce moment
quand il joue comme ça tu comprends
pourquoi il a eu ses chances contre carl
scène parce qu'en vrai plus long je
montre mieux il joue j'ai l'impression
oui je ne m'étonne pas en fait qu'il ait
bien joué ce match tu avec le recul je
m'étais pas rendu compte de cette force
de karuïa keane en amont du match contre
carl scène par des gens venant tous les
candidats y l'édition fatigué mais je
m'étais pas rendu compte à quel point il
était fort dans les moments importants
tu savais qu'il avait du sang froid mais
je pensais c'était juste son niveau
bougeait pas mais j'en ressens que ce
niveau il augmente c'est un genre de
super saiyan plus les preuves de la mort
plus ce qui ne me tue pas me voir quand
même très important ça tuerait merci
réflexion en fait pour le moment magnus
s'ajuste sur vos déboîté island est
encore à nom de fait la grosse malle
premier match des boîtes valenciennes
demain ça peut un peu plus tourner et
gagner le game coach contre sergei ouais
c'est ça et contre caruana gagnent il a
mieux joué globalement mais en vrai
ouais c'est bah disons il peut perdre la
petrov là où il ya maintenant 30
oui mais il peut perdre enfin je
trouverais temps 35 bons on comprend
bien mais qu à un moment juste à gagner
ou quelqu'un ça ne fasse un coût
d'impression défense et voilà et tu as
aussi la première à kickoff il permet en
fait j'ai fait un coup de hache trop je
sais pas quoi vous appartient pas et ça
tourne
mais peu lui devant voilà alors après le
match aurait pu basculer différemment si
la première ronde carlson gagnon il est
hyper bien c'est drôle imola qui devrait
perdre un bon jour ils ont tous les deux
eu leur chance avant oui c'est choquant
mais disons sur la vue d'ensemble du
match que carson conserve le titre c'est
plutôt logique mais
il ya quelques moments où tu sais ça
peut changer
après tu avais la superbe chanson
caruana aux nanas de jong hun sen au
nahd du cajon et onana donc ça ressemble
vraiment un marshal web à ce forum vous
faut comparer en fait vous redire cette
position est normalement celle là quoi
après bien lui c'est calme en faveur des
blancs bas c'est ce que je dirai
intuitivement mais parce que comme comme
dis donc ça c'est la version classique
du marshall qu'est ce que nous on a dans
la partie l'option n'est pas là le pire
n'est pas là la toile ah bon nous on a
une tour qui l'a fait rien qu'il a dans
la partie peut aller faire des trucs la
tourbe et 8 elle ferait mieux est
d'autant plus que les meurtres et selon
leur plan c'est de faire du faux f5 ou
g4 et et tour ici donc là tous repartent
de baby tous deux à huit pour atterrir
là c'est pareil alors que nous le fait
de voir faire ça c'est quand même cool
du coup du coup je dirais que c'est mes
relations pour les blu ray mais d'un
autre côté le marché est tellement bien
pour les noirs que peut-être sais pas si
c'était pas si grave tout à fait ce que
t'as pas perdus vraiment perdu un temps
parce que en vraie fête juste à fait
tourbe et 8 à 4 mais quand tu vas faire
tour et 8 la seule différence est que
les bleus entrent pour en fait soit mais
il aime bien faire 4 les blu ray je sais
mais ce que c'est vraiment mais je ne
sais pas non mais pour le coup on va
déjà je suis pas très experte du
marshall blanc parce que je le veux pas
rentrer dedans on va te j'ai un peu vu
ma chômage
je suis pas assez fin pour parler des
suds des nuances
donc c'est un peu
basic quoi ce que raconte là à mon
niveau je pense et bien c'est mieux ça
que la version normale pour les banques
et ça c'est cette phrase c'est vraiment
tout dire tu sais mais je sais pas faim
tu sais à ce niveau là c'est vraiment
autre chose
on propose ses 4 bat ces cas j'aime pas
trop non mais là pour le coup tu
justifies attend mon bébé d'un an der
thiam article mais aussi après marshall
c'est très fort les magistrats avaient
souvent ses sept tours là eh oui des
trucs comme ça mais là c'est la
satisfaction des trois pour contre la
glace de quatre pour filer la casse mais
en fait le truc c'est que duda il doit
réfléchir à toutes les ventes qui existe
sur l'autre ouais te dire oui non là ça
c'est pas très bon cause de sa nacelle a
vaincu ce qui est plus fort normalement
oui il ya beaucoup plus érudits et je
fais cette mauvaise varie en paix ce qui
est incapable de trouver la bonne
transposition suisse et fabien c'est
vraiment un très bon fois contre un tel
nom mais là tu peux passer longtemps
mais déjà je lui devais faire il devait
faire là en fait ce travail est ce que
le 4s que la tourneuse que le toit merci
à tous et je sais pas
c'est à ce moment là où tu dois plombé
la commune tant il réfléchit à ce qu'on
allait les temps
non ici on a le temps passe ici il a
fait huit minutes presque 9 mai sous tu
sais qu'il va faire des muscats de la
marche par la feinte ou pas logique en
ce que je vous disais moi je m'attends
qu à ça après je sais pas si vous vers
une autre idée mais j'aurais été surpris
donc du coup le tour e cas dont on
sortira bientôt la vidéo c'est le temps
d'une carrière et que tu as non mais ça
on l'a déjà sorti c'était le cahier de
vad
la tour en 4 fait quand ils font un f5
avec le pion detroit on peut on peut
filer la cale et reprendre en quatre
avec le pion surtout concierge et 5 dont
vous pouvez plus tard en fait l'idée f1
c'est trop rare alors disons qu'elle est
c'est-à-dire les noirs les 7 juin
prochain coup ils ont dû faire c'est
full attack la dame veut rentrer ici
veut mater si on fait trois purs des
sacrifices avons c'est chaud donc en
gros pendant longtemps ils ont été
contraints de faire tourner 408 fout là
et puis ça peut paraître à la tour de
venir là et de gagner la dame par
exemple on va dire ça hein pas de chance
tourne donc tours 4
5 ta case est en fait dix ans qu'on
fasse ça vous attaquent la tour qui est
des deux pour aller reprendre et bomba
différence en option soit là ou là des
choses comme ça ça peut mais peut-être
que l'on peut faire du coup que c'est
une différence avec ses deux tours la
oumma chat façon ça il faut vraiment
réfléchir ça se joue à des détails et
juste comme je vous disais moi je sais
pas je sais pas et pas assez rude et
donc bonjour ça est-ce que tours 4 tu
fais est ce que tu te dis je vais
ramener madame là bas bon ça je ferai
pas en fait mais adam des trois coups
des picots scop ouais ouais mais surtout
c'est le coup de cueillir ce moule il
proposait donc j'ai pris très au sérieux
un jour ce qui c'est mou je propose
juste parce que c'est pour être le coup
de pic au scope wysiwys dam des trois
ici possible ça a l'air très fort c'est
comme un crash samedi 3 1 et 5 pourquoi
pas fou préemption
un baiia de l'attaquant fait c'est
d'ailleurs littérature en d3 et que tu
défends ta tour et là tu ne font plus
rien et il ya les cinq fils de carla
être puis on prend et où tu mets le
carillon f-35 donc non à tours 4
donc j'ai 5 normalement c'est ça et si
tu as le pion detroit alors j'espère ça
la même position
voilà la tutelle enfin tu as le droit
qui a passé cinq quoi que la temps
qu'est ce tu t'en fous dame-là s'attaque
juste un foulard un fou et une tour même
montré de lens jean roger 5 même si tu
prends pas qui a et des deux justes ont
montré un truc imagine qui a aidé dans
mon fief cinq jeunes cavalières trois
ânes en kf3 pareillement peut-être
vendre tout axa c'est juste pour
illustrer sa vérité bref bien d une
petite différence des nuances way 4g 5
dans le far west tout à fait c'est
possible ça je pense possible quand vas
tu juste citer changé toujours la finale
mais du coup tu es content d'avoir fait
le a4
en fait c'est assez marrant ça me fait
repenser aux tribunaux bakic tu comptes
avec mpl mais moi je loupais c'est
carrément quand tu dis pas plus et être
toi qui peux revenir ai profité
ouais genre montre genre à 8 direct sera
compensée par exemple qui étudient merci
encore à ce jour là si merci que ça on
te fait chèque au roi et ont fait
attaque ça aussi donc le roi va devance
barré et en encaisse
il écoute toutes les noirs qui rentre et
des personnes ça bien sûr il peut avoir
analysé se dire les qu'on croit que
d'être cloné pour les blancs peut-elle
pas très fin mais ok bon il réfléchit en
tout cas tous ces trucs là en tout cas
tout re 4 et d'un fn c'est absolument
pas qu'on peut être à un autre couple
3,4 ici mais quand je vous dis
normalement ça n'a pas très envie de
voir quoi
c'est quand le bouquin les échecs simple
par picot scop scic aux scop c'est
tellement pas de l'aïe qui vont un
échange le fait un vote faut juste faire
ça mais prendre les pièces emprise si
ces leçons apprises en plus de la
simplicité à fait tord et quatre bombes
datant rage et 5 si tu fais les deux
c'était cité change tout et que tu
prends tes très fort quand même
vachement c'est une évidence
c'était tellement beau son dam des trois
évite le matin ce que ça fait échec
comme monde toulouse puis sur chaise
comme il est 2009 fait ce à quoi ils
échangent tout ce qu'ils ont changé one
toulouse déjà du temps attachement il
fait tomber apathie fait très peu de
fautes tactiques ils échangent tout
d'une chronique sur les cinq îles et du
tour h4 en photo l'intérêt du pion face
aux blancs ils vont dégager la dame en
fait appris de fond dames h 5 pouces et
2 et c'est peut-être ce qui vous la taxe
sur le roi puis ils vont alors se
développer et faire des choses quoi
partir
duda la faute ainsi fin moi j'aimerais
bien mettre une pièce sur au total sur
la partie ouest journée non moi je
reviens tout à gagner serait beau quand
même élimination de carabes scène par
d'août à fin juin
ce serait une belle perf ans de duda et
une belle qualif aux candidats et c'est
avec panache
surtout que duda lui il joue sous
pression parce qu'il a une place au
candidat magnus qui joue pour rien donc
il est avantagé ici tout d'alba quand
même c'est beau c'est beau la pression
cède parfois waouh ça dépend bien sûr
fait c'est mieux dans une petite dose de
pression pour pas joué en son fils jean
baggy suis quand même pour la gueule
mais c'est une pression je pense qu'il
est beaucoup plus sympa que plus sympa à
voir
je prends une tendresse se gagne pas à
tant pis mais tu joues pour gagner alors
que les corps derrière tout ça c'était
peut-être pas ces objectifs font de toi
enfin on ne sait pas il vient il se dit
bon je n'aime pas trop mauvais on va
voir mais j'ai pas un tableau si simple
bon je fais ce que je peux on verra tour
après tour te sens tu peux pas prévoir
mais tu viens pas avec un objectif comme
ça mais a fait plus que tu te rapproches
plus ces [ __ ] ça répondra t du coup
parce que là je suis comme pas loin et
est donc là forcément été rattrapé par
cette pression et être pas au début de
l'événement mais que t'as pas tout d'un
coup quoi me maquiller duda font des
espagnols contre manif mais en fait n'a
pas trop le choix et mais non en fait le
temps exact à son étoile et ça fait
quatre ou cinq bons 9,3 norman il fait
ça à 11 soit tu fais l'italienne tuffeau
l'espagnol avant une fois de temps en
temps tu fais un petit écossaise pour
surprendre mais normalement c'est moi
mon réputé on va dire
l'italienne et ils ont fait très souvent
pendant avant c'était un peu moins
analysé serait de l'espagnol bien sûr
c'était c'est l'ouverture meanstream sur
e4 e5 donc analysé depuis des siècles et
récemment mais bon est énormément
énormément ça a été l'ouverture de
classes championnat du monde est ok
c'est très intéressant mais donc
l'italienne en gros de base c'était un
peu l'ouverture des enfants on ne peut
plus fous rires des fenêtres on fait des
machins arbres mais ils ont prouvé que
c'était beaucoup plus fin que ça et il
ya des bons joueurs qui sont mis à le
jouer et puis de plus en plus et tout
d'un coup ils ont beaucoup analysé ils
ont tout décortiquer donc séduit autant
théorique que l'espagnol tus n'ai plus
faim on va dire ex-aequo et donc c'est
un peu pareil enfin l'un ou l'autre
façon c'est être un gros débat théorique
bas après on fait ce qu'on veut ça
dépend mais les cp annuelle à 4
cavaliers joie mais ça ressemble un peu
à une espagnole au final voilà quatre
tirs et donc c'est de faire ça ici
5 si on laisse le choix noir bas soit de
copier soin de mettre lequel on est
quatre d'ailleurs qu'un bon coup soi
même poussé cinqs pas mal fou des six
pour les gens un peu plus imaginatif
mais en fait ça reste moins bien réputé
et en gros si tu veux jouer pour quelque
chose espagnol sait très bien et
italiennes pas bête du tout mais quand
je vous dis il est tous les plans des
trucs très sophistiquée avec des
assisses à 5 ou la dame qui par là bas
des choses qu'on voyait pas au début il
ya cinq ans de sa personne faisant et
puis petit à petit à force de bien
analyser tout ça ils ont quand même bien
mais je dirais que l'on avancé notre
bagnole c'est les blancs ils ont quand
même la chance c'est plus ceux qui ont
des variations ouais alors bien sûr ici
on peut se heurter au berlin où ça mais
il ya d'autres lignes mais on ne voit
pas vraiment mais là en fait après en
gros l'autre truc très joué des blancs
cédé 3 qu'on n'a pas vraiment vu là dans
les parties aient été joué très
longtemps
l'idée c'est défendre l'option et voilà
3 et 5 fu laroque n'ont pas accepté
marshall normal on peut jouer h3 bas
d'ailleurs je pense qu'une partie
karékine ii magnus avec h3 faire à 4 ans
tim marshall fonds pour faire pas mal
quoi on peut faire des dégâts
enfin jacques c'est plus les blancs qui
ont l'embarras du choix la fin en fait
tu as on sait comme d'hab t'as rien qui
donne vraiment un avantage mais bonjour
votre la partie mais un petit refresh au
cas où
ouais si on s'est jamais adressé un coup
ci a eu un coup qu'on a pas être atteint
déjà son échelle de 5
ok normal cette dame est fin prêt cerise
et tours à huit voies ou pas je sais est
donc envoyé 4 5 il faut pas vous dire
qu'ils auront davantage blanc en quoi
que tu choisisses non je vous parfait
vous parfait mais spéciale s'est bien
italienne s'est bien fait où tout est
bien et tout est mal foutue prend comme
chez eux mais en fait de toute façon on
ne saura jamais si les noirs jouent
parfaitement entourage a mais davantage
nulle part voilà au moins c'est simple
et les autres alors quoi petits pions
lâche pas
qui évite que les north face des g5 et
des choses comme ça d'un coup j'aurais
bien aimé faire marcher avant peut-être
cb4 pour fêter ses 5 ans c'est le cas
dans des cas très etc
je sais pas hier en corse a juste l'air
bien préparé en fait ouais havre et à
vrai dire ça commence à sentir la nulle
ça sent la drôme ouais je peux rien dire
là-dessus
marty qui dictent fidow f pleats la
position qui est très complète mort soit
il est préparé sur les blogs
je ne sais pas quoi dire c'est pas que
l'un ou l'autre terrible terrible dirait
qu'ils bluffent comme marc tonique
peut-être une petite tâche de pub non
plus bas qu'un peu je pense à ce stream
qui manque de qualité que tu veux qu'on
fasse un peu comme hier on est parti un
peu fou le plus bas au monde au nez a je
pense qu'on a envoyé tube sur tube quoi
avec l'ami 6 minutes par heure tu as
donc la vraie chance à un moment donné
en fait on a un peu oublié puis après on
a fait beaucoup plus qu'on a commencé à
envoyer de partout je voyais des plus
opulente et et regarde encore une pub
après il ya des gens c'est un mets fins
donc un moment donné hier il ya vraiment
eu un énorme temps mort entre
15h40 non entre 15h45 et 18h30
c'est passé proche de m
2h45 un peu où tu te trompes la sieste
ouais ben non moi je lutte aimer les
autres du coup je les endormis et a mise
dehors immigrés je faisais un peu la
berceuse et où bonne nuit les petits est
là et plus pub et les gars étaient très
contents exaspéré mais ils étaient
intéressés mais renvoie une pub je
regarde les autres qui sont sortis les
pubs pour amazon les pubs pour amazon
prime pour suivre la ligue 1 donc du
coup tu vas y avait vraiment de
l'information et finalement le moment
pub à partir d'un moment et est devenu
plus qualitative que le stream moi j'ai
une telle pub moi j'ai une telle pub
fait un tueur voit les gens étaient
heureux grâce à la pub christian belz a
mis son prime va bien jouer à christian
de suite la pub fait son effet comme un
fou donc la pub a fait quand même
beaucoup de bien à dynamiser le stream
donc ça il faut qu'on commence là envoya
dynamiser tout de suite donc dame est
fin et coûte ce qui est bien c'est qu'on
n'a pas à raconter n'importe quoi
oui etc l'idée c'est sur suran reçoit
d'emprunt f1 et tour à 8 soit tous ravis
direct waouh dame préfère fois je trouve
chaque et tournevis ou body nature fief
cinq attaques la tour à toi vite j'en
ressens rien présager d'un toit à 8
direct parce que toi tu nuis un peu un
secouriste tu fais dame prend si tu fais
d'un reprend roi prend fois je crois que
tu as tes parents eux deux tu laisses un
peu le choix alors que vous tous ravis
tu le laisses bien cloisonné ici parce
que le zinc est jouable alors pas trop
trop intentions arrive s'aggrave
pourquoi ben non mais moi je vous trouve
et non et il doit retrouver le problème
9,5 racing quand je suis passé par
l'espanyol
gore verte a vu la joueuse espagnole à
17 ans qui a gagné l'espagne mixte à
moins de 18 c'est bien à deux reprises
bravo y est terrible pour les noirs
division d'illusions si f5
non c'est bien la petite
enfin je sais pas je la connais pas en
fait mais autour de 1300 lots et et elle
je crois qu'elle joue beaucoup me wade
ou camille kleiber on voit que quand on
fait ça juste à jouer dans cette
catégorie bas ça peut marcher quoi c'est
un bon exemple à suivre
et puis pour tout ce qu'ils ne venaient
que pôle gare et n'ont même pas n'en
fait il pas qu elles elles jouent au mix
depuis longtemps et est championne
d'espagne un quator mix moins de
quatorze elle joue en moins de 18 mois
le fait que deux mixages s'en fiche un
peu
il faut y aller faut y gagne par mail
mais bon à la combattre donc bon voilà
bravo à mes origines en bravo à elle et
c'est bien ça ça continue à prouver
toujours la même chose en fait si tu as
ça va dans le même moule un retour
alimenté par tout ça mais non non c'est
bien bravo à elle est en tout cas et
j'espère qu'elle fera une belle carrière
un coup les padres ont fait bien le
prince dont je suis très heureuse
toujours au soleil allez-vous faire là
seul endroit de tout l'appartement il ya
du soleil je vais super chaud on subit
je n'ai pas assez de poil à ce très
froid faisait très froid très froid dans
cette foule
magnus et leurs assesseurs un même si
lula est parti un peu reprendre haye la
distance mon ami c'est juste prépare
préparé par ed magnus aide les glissades
ce monde
somone ses beaux cheveux sales made of
someone semaine à serralongue des sceaux
venait de se connaître soi-même se
monnaient des marches à l'aide espagnole
s quel genre se lève comme ça ils sont
surveillés pour éviter la tricherie
oui mais non comme f1 te sens-tu qu'ils
aillent où ils peuvent pas quitter la
salle de jeux dans l'eau chaude ou quoi
mais après c'est sûr est que ni vlad du
coin se sont mis un capteur tel capteur
mais je pense qu'il ya un truc où tu pas
son petit ouais mais si tu c'est très
très très mal hein t'as pas un seul
indice que les fouilles ont été
suffisantes ne sont pas suffisantes de
ce point de vue là peut-être en chine et
je le ferai mais il comprend pas les
fouilles ne me paraissent pas suffisante
avant et après les parties pourraient
bien sûr aussi ses problèmes c'est
fantastique ça explique pourquoi ils
sont aussi bien longtemps payé pour
jouer tu sais que l'histoire des
toilettes où il y avait deux toilettes
gate avec toi pas fait cramer rik
depuydt l'histoire de rosis d'ailleurs
et pour d'autres peu importe mais là
pour des tournois comme ça ils peuvent
pas faire ils sont fouillés je pense pas
qu'on puisse amener de electronic device
à la partie tout ça c'est vraiment très
contrôlée pour la peine donc là y'a pas
il n'y a pas de suspicion à voir
du tout mais bon vlad quand même par
sécurité oui bien sûr donc barre mais
bien sûr enfin les tournois on peut se
poser question ça se fait des trucs mal
contrôlée genre les trucs sur internet
ou quoi ou là bon bien sûr je t'attends
à tout et n'importe quoi éventuellement
mais la torah comme ça il ya pas de
doute il ya toujours un et pas de risque
zéro
non mais sauf si mais que ses branches
et une puce dans le cerveau un truc
d'une technologie incroyable mais 0 non
parce qu'en fait tu vois moi je pense
que quand tu attrapes un peu des gens
comme au vélo tu limite le risque même
quand tu attrapes jamais vraiment
personne je ne sais pas ça m'inquiète un
peu
parce qu'en fait surtout les joueurs qui
vous ces tournois là depuis tellement
d'années il ya forcément déjà eu
quelqu'un qui a marabouté et moi je
parle de ce principe là du fait qu'ils
aient jamais personne qu'ils se fassent
prendre ça m'inquiète un peu
ah je sais pas fins tu as aimé quand moi
j'étais aux olympiades j'ai vu je vois
pas trop quand tu peux faire en route
justement il ya eu fait mais maintenant
c'est un protocole qui fait que tu
passes ça c'est comme les aéroports en
fait on tu rentres tu as lattes et le
détecteur m'acharne depuis ton sac
on n'était vraiment pas à l'abri quoi
donc et morale d'agir même une canette
de coca ne fait pas la rentrée faut bien
ouvrir mais maintenant il est vrai que
la plus interne ça fait vraiment peur ok
mais un truc de puces way s'est tue pas
son reste plus qu'a fait tuer un cyborg
quotidien ces 18 mai non mais ça c'est
enfin ça m'inquiète vraiment faim sans
rigoler en fait la centrale ça
m'inquiète vraiment ce truc là parce que
c'est très facile à faire
c'est pas très coûteux bah ça peut
rapporter beaucoup d'argent
tu peux voir des nids lentilles des
trucs je ne sais quoi mais non mais si
tu t'es fait greffer une puce au niveau
de l'intestin par exemple d'un petit
stockfisch de ventre de poche mathurin
bluetooth vibre en fait ouais
des cordes mittal je dois passer quand
même un petit truc comme ça sans
plastique la taille d'une carte sim
je ne fais pas à prendre avec un truc
aussi petit elle ferait quoi la puce bas
elle discuterait en mars en morse on
donnerait les coûts une vibration le roi
de vibrations la tourte aux régressions
cavaliers après les colonnes quoi une
vibration un bébé après les 1 2 3 machin
jusqu'à 8 mettez les rayons x à tout va
mais chez toi tu peux faire contre ça
mais pourquoi une issue par alain quand
tu peux prendre trois à quatre millions
d'euros par an avec les tournois
franchement on est sur dix ans ça te
fait 40 millions d'euros je connais des
gens qui ont fait des trucs moins
désagréable pour 40 millions de balles
adverses c'est quand même des très gros
ça mais il faut voir que par exemple le
cycliste a des gens qui ont mis fin
malheureusement leur vie en danger pour
beaucoup moins d'argent là c'est quand
même des sommes énormes et que tu mets
pas vraiment ta santé en danger
on voit des cyborgs
non mais ça m'inquiète vraiment pas
juridique
c'est vous quelque chose qui aujourd'hui
c'est plus de la science fiction c'est
vraiment dans le domaine du possible
non mais fait rarement des contrôles
très poussées en fait je faire passer à
des contrôles avant 2 ou frigide truc
c'est ultra spots had et comment il a pu
se revoir les coûts de la guerre ça mais
c'est juste quelqu'un à l'extérieur qui
enverrait des messages à la puce c'est
pas
si nous on est là avec la turbine et qui
est belle envolée version direct et que
là on lui envoie du morse lissacois un
brouillard de fréquence ces séries les
oui mais le brouillard de fréquences
pour avoir bossé à la fille justement
c'est très difficile à mais du coup
peut-être plus faire des chèques de haut
niveau c'est cardiaque tu ferais pas
l'utiliser au niveau du fresnoy et
d'oignons une faute du coup donc en très
débrouillarde par un médecin mais avec
apple pas que ça ya ça il ya un deuxième
problème c'est pour abu salah fit enfin
je le sais en russie réussissent à le
faire mais assez les services secrets
qui veulent jamais tu face à un genre
dans les pays européens
pourquoi sécurité nationale en fait ils
veulent pas donné d'autorisation pour de
tels de telles choses ces codes pin
saint louis à mousser ou rien parce que
ça brouille un peu plus loin et juste il
faut une autorisation spéciale et c'est
difficile à obtenir
bah je me rappelle que c'était un
problème d'obtenir l'autorisation d'être
un prérequis envers toi t'en as qu'une
brouillard
non mais en soi c'est quelque chose qui
m'inquiète ce que ok pour les temps à un
haut niveau candidat ou quoi bon tu y
arriveras plus ou moins tu peux choisir
un pays où c'est possible
genre la russie mais pour des tournois
un peu plus petit ça peut vite devenir
un un souci en fait
batta sont en fait il ya une histoire
avec le ivanoff là ils ont jamais rien
on se bat il arrêtait les échecs comme
ils l'ont dégagé 1 tour 9 s'il voulait
pas montrer si je suis bon en fait on
sait pas exactement ce qu'ils faisaient
mais peut-être bien qu'il ait une
machine en ses chaussures un engin
kouame
ivanov c'était un bulgare 25 30 ans à
peine 2000 2005 il a un mais des
français tout le monde donc et puis pas
qu'un tournoi pas déjà assez passant
salariés mais si la wii enfin j'ai très
envie qu'une des pièges je ne peux pas
montrer enfin au qu'il a jamais voulu
faire donc du coup ils l'ont viré
et puis mais qu'on l'a plus jamais vu
mais quand on sait pas si la triche pas
une conviction buy list
j'ai une conviction je crois qu'on est
nombreux à avoir cette conviction mais
tout cas il ya peu de femmes en déniant
à tout ça pour dire que ce truc de puces
c'est pour moi c'est enfin elle je sais
qu'il jour du haut niveau qui ont déjà
débordé pour je fais le fou y note le
gérant laurent de véhicules en russie
trop longtemps voire savoir et c'est
vraiment possible juste n'a pas été fait
par la personne que je connais qui a
demandé mais vous le savoir je voulais
juste savoir si c'était possible et il
se trouve que oui il se trouve que
c'était possible mais oui non il avait
demandé pour juste pour savoir si
c'était déjà dans le domaine du possible
et c'est jusqu'en fin c'est même facile
en fait non mais tu peux t'on enfin tu
vois bien ce que tu peux pas tu reviens
sur instagram que d'implanter des choses
cela pourquoi pas par aj al-hachémi
blague elle était pareil j'ai en fait tu
vois que tu fais à bernard mais bon
j'aime bien l'idée du brouillard
on te brûle tout voilà oui mais c'est
juste pour dire que en fait ce truc là
moi c'est enfin ça m'inquiète vraiment
parce que je me dis c'est facile ça
rapporte beaucoup d'argent est pour le
moment un but qui a personne qui s'est
fait choper ça doit rester quelque chose
de très faisable
je vais m'en remettre aux échecs corner
où je me couche fort que toi tu ne
connais rien en face les rien 2007 même
ennemi on ne perdra plus jamais une
seule se bat avec cette prépa
qualitative à ça c'est sûr
kissi café le en vrai nom mais fait
citer deux mille sept cents imagine t
tu gagne 3 à 4000 euros par mois je
pense après ce qu'ils gagnent aussi 7000
pas 21 22 ans tes joueurs talentueux et
tu dis ok je peux faire ça et je passe
de trois à quatre mille par an - à 40 50
mille chevaux des changes a battu dit
bon je fais c'est un an ou deux j'arrête
puis bon après tu continues en fait je
dire c'est assez calme assez tente enfin
de te dire tu peux gagner 500 amalgame
assez de temps pour un truc tu prends un
risque quand même très mesuré un petit
moteur dans le vélo une fois de temps en
temps à étudier cette course et offre
aux étudiants est quand même pas ou
alors un petit moteur froid faim non
mais c'est ça en fait et je pense
qu'après tu peux tomber dans le cercle
vicieux et on voit pas de j'aurais bien
vu un bon démarrage officiel qu un
implant de puces et détectables au
toucher mais je crois pas qu'on touche
trop largement pas qu'on touche au roi
on pirate passe le gars est tous des
trucs comme ça mais disons pour faire
une fouille il faut tout mettre sa
remontée en france avait pas n'importe
qui qui peut être fan faut y voi pont de
kehl foutu par le prêtre est assermenté
quoi je suis même pas sûr qu'on est en
assermentés bas des jambes au patro vys
ya les papiers d'identité quoi donc mon
l'avion et tout ça faisait dix gendarmes
plus nationale en fonction de ça non
mais sauf si on accuse de fraude de des
deux volets du fric du coup tu triches
tu voles quoi mais bon pas si j y tiens
allez fouiller monsieur families skis à
saint-etienne 7 35 à 35 voile de la ss
michel platini
ils habitent là je vends si une fraude
pour lui titles effet très important et
je peux vous dire où est implantée la
puce j'ai une très belle idée
bada qui vient chez toi je pense pas que
tu fasses a enfin la chance pour un
mandat pour faire ce genre de trucs un
policier peut exiger de te fouillé et je
pense heureusement que vlad n'est pas
flic en fait dans ma vie je ne veux pas
me soucier des veines mais cette
personne mais j'ai rien contre
l'identité normalement c'est vraiment
réservé police gendarmes
vous avez fait vous rouliez à 52 km h au
lieu de 50 je pense que vous faites du
trafic va vraiment faire une fouille
très simple du coup tous les trois en
russie août le droit un peu plus trop
quand maxime qui se pose à jamais le
moindre truc c'est si à la place d'un
brouilleur de signaux on mettait en
place un détecteur de six heures mais je
sais pas du tout à quel point ça peut
être efficace à et tu veux juste bloquer
tous les signaux de tous du coup avant
que toutes et tous soient éteints
vraiment quoi pas un téléphone rien mais
bon il met les ordinateurs et les
échiquiers dgt tout il donne un signaux
électriques ça passerait pas alors aux
transports à l'ancienne un mec placé en
tribune bien haut avec des jumelles qui
voit ce que tu fais et retransmet les
coûts ah j'en sais rien elle fera
fléchir mais si le jour ça devient
vraiment un cas tu dois en fait je me
demande si tu doit blinder le truc et
moi j'ai la question moi je me parce que
c'est pas déjà c'est pas déjà le cas et
justes a pas de cap parce que personne
n'y pense mais moi c'est une question
que je me pose vraiment en fait comme ça
monsieur
non mais après il ya quand même des
joueurs suspects machin sur le circuit
tout fin juin faut dire les choses comme
elles sont coiffe un jour tu te demandes
des fois avoue que tu tu arrives que tu
te poses des questions vraiment mesure
je comprends mais en fait c'est juste
que tu te poses des questions parce
qu'il ya passé contrôler la non peu
importe je peux en première partie sur
ce chemin on est parti en fait c'était à
côté de marans en fait moi je voulais
juste faire une fouille sur 40 cents 0
je veux vraiment être bien sur quoi je
sais pas on a compris et complètement
glissé quoi bon se montrent une bonne
page de pub pour fêter ça quoi
en réalité il ya vraiment un risque puce
qui existent corps hors 3 le 100% notre
hall s'est passé on vit pas une blague
en fait non mais ça c'est pas une blague
ça peut vraiment déjà existé sans qu'on
le sache métier c'est un peu comme les
moteur dans le vélo tu as les gens il
commence à y penser à en parler et puis
dix ans après ils ont découvert cet
effet depuis bien longtemps mais juste
en fait les gens qui ont eu le
pressentiment que ça pouvait exister
mais c'est aussi ça va mais cru 2010 en
disant comme ça et non mais le truc pour
la peine d'un gars que je connais qui a
fait la demande et où c'était possible
c'est no fake et qui l'a pas fait c'est
no fake aussi en tout cas il n'a rien
gagné depuis qu enfin ils contestent
rien du tout fou de plus ne marche pas
s'il ya du coup eric serra du tout mais
il a vraiment demandé jean à la
poussette n'ont pas su prévoir sur donc
magnus réfléchi se décide
complexe
dire à première vue j'en sais rien mais
[Musique]
c'est une blessure compliquée pourquoi
pas enfin avec les blancs il a fait
aussi son j'imagine c'est pour ce qu'il
veut à cette casse pour le cavalier pour
s'incruster éventuellement les rebondir
là bas et conseils de chiens près je me
demande d'amm b6 qu'est ce que est ce
que c'est et c'est de la merde en fait
d'après leurs dix cavaliers la nôtre 6-3
ok ça c'est pas trop dur à voir face
juste là on n'analyse pas trop que notre
cerveau moquer d'un grand gros le truc
logique de boue philippe yon c'est pas
possible c'est pour ça qu'avec innova ce
pion un pion soit six étrangers bien sûr
c'est très fort dans les finales ou quoi
mais l'envié de jeu on peut le trouver
désolidarisés du reste des pièces
saisies rebond bas c'est une faiblesse
je ne bouffe est vrai que la présence de
sous ici mais beaucoup de temps en rien
le manger donc ça laisse un peu de temps
blanc et donc l'arrêt de carré keynes
allait faire ça donc c'est concret en
fait s'il perd le pion avait très mal
s'il reste en vie qui plante un cahier
là bas et qui te fait froid et compagnie
bah ça va être bien un coup donc propos
cible que ce soit très bien pour les
blancs avoir concret et carl saine
réflexion triche occasionnelle on ne
peut pas les siens au nouveau gm s'ils
gagnent cognin ça se verra traité mais
c'est pour ça que je parlais d'un gars
qui serait à 2007 2016 distingua déjà
fort qui suis restée un petit bout c'est
comme un peu du compte c'est la
cancellara ça a été je crois que les
moteurs il y avait le moteur mais il a
été très très très très très fort et en
plus c'est une petite tape harvey dent
on va dire si si si en gros moi je
deviens champion du monde est un
problème mais si tu prends un mec plus
ou moins jeunes en lettonie non parce
que j'ai vraiment à les croire 30e
mondial où on peut se dire ok déjà 2007
2007 20 machin il a fait du bien il a le
droit de bien jouer et d'un coup il a dû
travailler pendant confinement et trucs
bon mais je joue bien un truc tu le vois
arriver petit à petit si le mec qui fait
pas une option a fait chaque tournoi et
qui laissera un peu normaux voilà et
puis un moment il donnait champion du
monde bon c'est dans le domaine du
possible
ça jamais été prise hier je pense que ça
a été prouvé cancellara je sais pas si
ça a été vrai y avait un truc cancer mon
peu importe j'ai pas dû trop trop donné
tellement de fric
car bon tu prendras un mec de cet acabit
vraiment déjà lors de battues avec elle
mais qui fut champion du monde tout
débat pourquoi pas enfin il peut faire
bafin mais si rien de choquant qu'il ait
fait coincer sa suspicion mais le vélo a
disparu d'accord la fois utilisé par m
comment la puce transmettra
l'information aux joueurs ben elle
aurait un soin par infrarouge soit par
par bluetooth afin par une techno un
bavoir départ en mission essentielle si
la sonarges jouer et que tu veux lui
dire fais d'un programme
tu vas trouver un moyen quoi ça tu dis
f1 s'est dit d'am-dam soit 20 tu te
medac fin je sais pas quoi ça c'est pas
trop compliqué
à une classe
tous ces progrès technologiques
il faut prendre en compte ça existe et
tu dois qui t'a pas être parano mais
lutter contre des possibles truc comme
ça au moins c'est bien sûr le plus
possible on avait déjà des cas de triche
un câble au poker poker c'est vraiment
pas compliqué d'élaborer une
communication codé non non ce n'est pas
un complexe en fait c'est pas quelque
chose ça hein c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui vraiment bien plus réfléchis
un peu avant de fermer parce que la
science fiction
enfin ça allait plus je pensais à 10 ans
c'est dur là aujourd'hui ça me paraît
visuellement ça paraît pas mais je pense
faudrait que réagir en amont de saint
fort et déjà commencé peut-être caché à
personne qui le fait encore un nom mais
j'ai commencé je ne sais pas c'est pas
de la parano de penser que c'est
possible en fait
faudrait déjà intervenir qui bloqueront
que qu'est-ce qui travaillent un peu
dans ce domaine là je connais la
transition par ondes est tout à fait
possible pas forcément évidentes pour
être discret mais pour moi c'est
faisable
le gars qui t'a informé qu'ils avaient
raison mais c'est que ça coûtait cher et
pas c'était pas 1000 ou 2000 euros quoi
c'était cher mais ça se rembourser en un
tournoi quoi tu gagnes un truc c'est
remboursé après les frimas de le prêter
à des freerolls
bon jusque là
la france hm2f un étrange on pensait que
c'était prépa prépa et aux autos qui est
content réfléchir pas des fois t'es tu
sais le coup d'état mais leur entrée
dans le truc c'est après pas finie
peut-être bien enfin serait bon de
tomber et tombait bien on dit c'était
impossible on développe déjà des piles
eu avec caméra intégrée pour détecter
les cancers à l'intestin et c'est
autrement plus complexe de transmettre
des images ouais donc tu vois c'est
vraiment déjà très simple en bref donc
c'est vraiment possible
alors forcément ça nous avons c'est un
truc c'est dommage que je sois pas pris
dans la commission anti cheating de la
fidh je pense que je serai très parce
que je suis assez imaginatifs et je
déteste vraiment les gens qui trichent
ça va être vraiment profondément et donc
je pars en profiter non en fait je
déteste profondément et je suis très
inventif du coup je l'imaginais des
idées de partout je retiens ils peuvent
faire comme ça et faire comme ça il peut
faire comme ça vient vérifier mais je
prends
d'intervenants terrain on sera une
équipe de choc quoi il y aurait plus
personne qui aurait gagné les tournois
très peur oui je me fais me non je ne
veux surtout pas me qualifier
tullow qui perd gagne un vrai
interdiction d'abondants 30e coup
allemand très difficile reviendrai quand
même nom c'est maman qui n'est pas là
c'est en fait ils nous ont posé la
question quand ils partent ce qu'on lire
ici voilà c'est comme ça
non mais je me disais ce que tu penses
qu'il marche trop bien ou pas est ce
qu'ils ne jouent pas trop bien allons
intervenir badia ça va ça sert à quoi
j'ai pas de doute sur duda mais bon déjà
c'est un combat très atteint donc qui
sait déjà quelles difficultés à des kits
de soin le code mais empêche c'est
rassurant que maxime se fasse éliminer
maxime et régression en fait foi les
absences fin tu peux lui française
vraiment il a une puce archos très dur
quoi absence j'ai pas compris le code de
ba qui coiffe a tenté j'ai cliqué au
hasard kiko hasard ministre en sueur
poutine qui rigole je suis à vue encore
comment débrouiller à technologie ips
est vraiment très facile que ça les
hackers russes encore et je lui dis de
ne pas faire tourner en mcad baissera le
pousse ses pions
au fric il ya des absences en fait je
pouvais rien faire je n'avais rien gagné
en gagnant tous les ans dit est ce que
j'ai dit hier dans le sud sa trésorerie
l'intelligence humaine est déjà
inférieur dans le domaine des échecs à
d'autres intelligences qui existe sur
terre non pas des extraterrestres est en
hausse aussi de l'intelligence qui te
dépasse les formes y convergeront cramer
c'est terrible elle serait beaucoup à
magnus un peu se lever se remettre le
pantalon comme ça se grattant un peu les
élèves et tout d'un coup sar capte et y
joue pas au golf alors on s'attend à une
position tout comme ça on sait pas trop
mais bon t'as qu'à maintien au moins un
vrai lien a besoin de moi tu faire
ceinture revient enfin tester voir un
pion de suspect c'est la turbine a
trouvé un truc oeil mais en plus ça
bascule c'est sûrement ça prépare en
fait une tête qui se rappellent plus tu
peux pas prendre de tomates et d'autres
films faits à tournon plus tes mains et
bas du coup sûr un coût et puis bon tu
vas tu as changé et c'était externe a
mis l'affairé
on reprend forcé n'est pas d'autres coup
légal on s'attend à foisches trois
échecs au roi il peut faire très vite
avant évidemment
et alors on va bouger alors notre pays
même et ça change tout ici peut aller en
me donnant ouais mais ce que c'est si
bien ce que le toit patron ps on n'est
pas allé du dos de qualité et qu'il
n'est pas folle et en fait de nommer
qualité d'ailleurs de tout faire un
clémence une chance de lyon ouais mais
il va pas avoir toute la préparation
mais en fait ce qui est bon ce trois
fois trois ans je pense tu peux voir
prépare aide beaucoup faut acheter
parfois sans quoi on peut être que fred
funk c'est jouable tout à fait mario
seul je ne sais pas fois je crois juste
eu force bien les choses la danette
il revient [ __ ] par un après ça se
trouve une tour en 8 ou quoi et tu peux
jouer mes membres et ses sept tours qui
peut te rentrer sa part être tour à huit
lits des menaces tu feras vide en fait
je crois qu' il s'en fout en fait est ce
que tu vas faire
qu'est ce qui te battre ça déjà saint
amarin qui a été peu après et nous tous
ressentent une développe et puis comme
on dire tu va bondir tu as et examiner
sous la chaleur exemple le nom en plomb
utilisé en médecine indétectable seul
contrôle possible c'est le contrôle des
transmissions le détecteur de mensonges
a dit non mais en fait c'est en fait les
têtes les échecs ça va vite devenir un
jeu mort nous sommes loin non mais c'est
vraiment bien en russie pour les
candidats etc
il met vraiment le brouilleur genre vlad
me disais que les candidats à berlin tu
peux même pas payer par carte bleue ah
oui
l'australien est grand ils font les
retransmissions du coup parce que ces
filières
mais toute technologie non filaires
s'était enfoncée alors c'est l'éternité
ouais c'est que parfait rien utiliser
sans fil bad wifi pad c'est bien sûr à
berne ne sait pas quand ils ont fait
l'aller 4-1 boersma berlin les champs
aux hommes femmes enlève sa chemise
bombal fois que ce qu'ils ont déjà fait
l échange de dames
mais peut-être que tu dois faire dans
tous les temps à des chèques maintenant
par monta pas le roi mais moi je t'aime
mon pour notamment réussir est alors
plus le problème c'est quand tu joues
contre quelqu'un dont j'ai des doutes
cette même s'il fait pas tes tongs
psychose mais je sais je sais donc c'est
injouable
bah c'est pour ça que moi j'arrive pas à
jouer contre les contamines sûr tu as
même j'arrive juste pas c'est physique
et je comprends en fait c'est à doutes
sur quelqu'un même si fait rien en fait
tu peux pas la terrasse y aurait quand
même brouilleurs t rassuré parce que
franchement si la bouille brouilleur de
injuste c'est parfait bon moi je serai
là qu'est ce que tu peux faire tes kahn
bloqué un bébé qui avait quatre jours je
peux pas dire je sais pas du tout s'il y
avait des brouilleurs d'ondés pendant
les parties
si tu pouvais payer par carte bleue 6 à
20 min mara côté qu'il faut utiliser ta
carte bleue c'est qu'ils n'avaient pas
d'emploi de ma vie à berlin il y avait
c'est sûr mais il savait en fait juste
bizarre s'ils n'ont pas mis à terre un
bourg mais peut-être qu'ils peuvent plus
le faire je sais que ce n'était pas
évident à faire
avec en guise de modulation specific
antigen y avait peut-être que même ça ça
marche plus mais ça pourrait vraiment
être la mort des échecs en vrai si ça
c'est pas rien
on va dire à un moment ils vont réagir
la tête tu te fais avoir pour quelques
années
[Musique]
autant me démarque du feu peu importe
mais toujours est il qu'à un moment tu
comprends tu te dis oui bon difficile de
gruger le brouillard mais après c'est la
course à l'armement m et sera comme dans
les autres disciplines sportives en fait
ça a été détruit une honda compte
retrouver
on reprend f1 bon sinon tu fais ou à
poils courts
ouais mais face ou là pour m ouais tu
les fais passer en revue de l'aéroport
la grèce ou à tout ça tu peux
en tout cas c'est vrai qu'on devrait
enfin l'asse
si on commence maintenant serait déjà en
retard contre pour saturer
mais bon tant qu'on sait maintenant mais
ce serait déjà du retard j'ai fait jouer
son pour cage de faraday
mais c'est peut-être même pas oui c'est
pas une cage de faraday
en fait je pense
brouillonne ouais mais ça c'est le cas
de farhad et oui mais là tu es vraiment
tranquille ouais non mais c'était
intéressant c'était plus constructif que
d'habitude les gens dans le chat on
était assez intéressant pour une fois
ils ont compris que c'était possible
vous restez pas contre de précédentes
les gens à une prise de conscience là
dessus on aurait propagé 5
bah c'est pas d'une joaillerie jouer
brême mais peut-être qu'il apprendra
plus tard à voir ce que vont faire enfin
karl scène on s'attend bonsoir au f5
mais plus probablement fois je trois
échecs d'après ce que j'en ai vite fait
je croirais ici et reprise de la colonne
verte
les blondes avait changé a priori celle
de la varende prendre et après nord
veulent envahir un peu figé dans la
creuse n'y a pas de risque c'est une
très bonne idée quoi j vais la jouer en
picardie c'est oui
bourdon ça devrait bien aller au concert
très très bien
donc c'est bon c'est vrai tu le 2011 y
avoir joué à bollaert et donc en fait
présent c'est rare il vient de jouer ça
il vient de reprendre une dame ici donc
c'est ça ma guise au jeu avec les noirs
qui du coup va soit attaqué la tour donc
a priori ces moyens de prendre pied au
bout de femme jeune tour soit mettre
échec et du couffo par l'échec
après six sur six joue un coup comme
tour des huit l'apprendre le pion ça
serait pas mal moi je suis inquiet un
pour manu ce là je trouve moins fort que
duda un bain duda il a maîtrisé en
calcul hier à l'est encore aujourd'hui à
peut-être thierry s'anime j'ai
l'impression que bouddha il est juste
plus fort que carlson temps à force de
marine est ce qu'on va cuire du fait foi
je crois toujours invite macha salaire
juste d'aller tranquillou quoi après
wu dawei 5 après en attaque la tour et
donc on pensait qu'il faut à achraf
d'éditer mieux mon phone on sait trop
rien et donc faut être sain qui
attaquent la tour et on se disait bas
font rentrer à la maison après toujours
avoir les idées de laisser la qualité
qui est des deux jours ça paraît bizarre
c'est cool mais c'est vrai que pourquoi
pas on dira tout à l'air plus frais en
tout cas il y avait rester moins
longtemps sur les étals tout à fait de
bien marcher bonne condition physique
frêle 5 sur un tueur et feuilletons 14.8
français prendrait 5 il ya deux pions
isolé oui c'est l'activité l'acquis
comptant pour les noirs fait sur cette
position
ok il ya des plus isolés par tous est un
pion pour ninja theme d'assez de meute
jarry chèque au roi tu vas y si une tour
qui y ont été une grosse menace apparaît
la paire de fou et pénible talent fou
qui peut s'incruster la majorité de
pions elle est là c'est très dur de
créations passées les cases blanches tu
vois pas le jour avec toutes les pions
comme ça et on soutient noir donc tu
vois tous les problèmes que tu as après
une tête sur un très bon jeu les blues
devraient les droits peut-être pouvoir
faire nul mais c'est pas tout simple et
clairement c'est plus facile avec un
argent de choses en fait le truc c'est
pas forcément qui dit psion isolé ou
qu'ils aient des faiblesses visuel ce
qui compte aussi c'est que tu puisses
d'agde et ses faiblesses et que tes
pièces jouent bien
la situation qui à la pensée une trudeau
nemirovitch vous disait que les montrer
il parlait des colonnes ouverte un de
ses élèves ou quoi et le mec qui
montrent qu'une partie très fiers
quelques mois après vous regarde bien il
a sacrifié ses deux tours pour une
colonne du liban oui face à bientôt
vernis colle admeta plus de place pour
les dessus quoi fallait aussi des pièces
pour aller dessus c'est un peu comme un
camelot plus d'essence dans les colonnes
non mais c'est ça être un tu vois les
pions faibles elles sont faibles si tu
peux les attaques et les bouffer mais
qui sont juste là bas ils sont là ils
sont pas faibles du coup il faut prendre
ça vraiment tu fais si t'as pas trop le
choix ou site à tour arrivé tu penses à
collecter mais j'ai envie de dire en
général quand tu as un truc comme ça
comme un fou qui peut prendre des 5 eca
que toi qui peux le faire ya que toi qui
peux prendre et que le quart eli il a
aucun rebond intéressant je le fais par
an je sais vraiment au dernier moment où
tu te fais jamais de succès jamais mais
j'ai en fait tu fais tu as n'importe
quel tour tu peux le faire si par bailly
son va-tout à 26 par là bas qu'est ce
que de la faire un monde qui est mieux
bon c'est pas ce pas clair enfin c'est
soit duda soit égal en fait t'as tes
affaires spatiales quelqu'un qui est
mieux c'est tout
oui voilà n'allait pas mais le truc
c'est que tu peux bien finir par perdre
même si ce moment là t'es pas encore
moins bien du tout la tour 1 tour 8 faut
300 musulmans ça va doit pouvoir aller
mais c'est s'est dit également
et 400 beccaria kim pardon jacky noisy
il a fait son système de self réfléchit
à fond
c'est bon on a lancé un beau débat pour
une fois le débat est construit et je
suis très heureux de ce chat parce que
pour une fois ils sont pas là oui si
c'est des joueurs de haut niveau
c'est sûr qu'il ne triche pas comment un
grand maître pour écrire ils ont
vraiment conscience du truc maintenant
c'est bien une prise de conscience je
suis fier de vous c'est comme au tour de
france c'est sûrement les gars du top 10
qui sont dopés au remake 70e ont lu très
suspect pendant un an non et c'est
pareil dans tous les sports c'est
forcément les plus forts les plus tu
fais ce père que les autres font pas
mais c'est à dire que c'est ce qu'il
faut contrôler le plus en fait si tu
gagnes tout va sauter vraiment plus fort
mais moi comme ma fille c'était vraiment
naturellement plus fort ou pas quoi
c'était naturel ou peint permanent que
c'est possible surtout il ya dix ans
c'était pas possible
et là tu avec tous les jeunes qui
arrivent et où tu vas jamais pouvoir
savoir en fait cette chose
la fouille des chances et le des
fouilles en fait vraiment très
intéressant dernier fou pour être filmés
pour être bien sûr que pour moi car
iachini la foule tricher c'est
affligeant non pas du tout mais bon non
je pense pas non plus on est les foules
naturel mais surtout que c'est longtemps
qu'il est fort que machin est tout pour
moi il est 2 100 % naturel mais ça
n'empêche pas que il faut déjà chuté sur
le problème petite fouille quoi vous
rendre dans le mouvement mais qu'il faut
quel niveau pouvoir bien triché sans se
faire engueuler conférence de presse
évoquant les noms des rues jusqu'à quel
niveau je dois progresser pour pouvoir
faire rager pas 2007 une carrière très
intéressant j'ai peut être quarante
cinquante mille
ça va être un métier très intéressant
les grosses sommes j'ai fait des trucs
ils tant mieux parce que sa défense
construit même veille c'est sûr eu marc
barr c'est très dur mais c'est faisable
façon sur une partie tout est faisable
en fait à vrai dire non invasive
terrible sinon cette partie là c'est que
finalement il n'avait pas trop le choix
la souris fait ce coup soit ils
abandonnent chaque fois papa chaque fois
mais pendant plusieurs coups quasiment
et du coup par élimination tu veux
trouver des fonds ouais bon tu trouves
jamais tu perds mais la famille a laissé
comme carl scène ou quoi c'est la
défense par élimination il est hyper
fort par élimination en fait c'est
toujours seul coup ce qui est
impressionnant quand même hein mais
c'est assez son pouvoir fort et toujours
signaler qu'il était top de monde quoi
ouais il l'appela louise de la défense
parce que c'est ce qui fait bien quoi
défendre les positions chiante vous
trouvez les seuls coûts machin il sut
pas trop il est là il fait son truc
moi je sais pas c'est son truc mais
voilà
mon instrument de blocage phares comme
d'hab à partir de 14h45 jusqu'à 17
heures généralement ça ça ralentit un
peu le rythme mais c'est un peu poussif
après suivant les positions ça peut être
un peu poussif aussi de 17h à 18h30
ouais on verra bien quand grosse ça peut
être aussi de 14h45 à 9h30 battons pas
répondre franck qui demande six autres
choses que tout reste possible
alors toi ainsi clairement couvre ainsi
va le faire qu'à l'idée de se donner une
qualité et une qualité mais tu ailles
tête depuis un temps déjà et peut-être
de repas ce que c'est intéressant
moi j'aime bien visuellement ça je ferai
pas jamais se fait pas des pions je
reconnais mais les avancées il ya pas
mal de cole haan ouverte mais qui ça
pour moi je me sentirai moi j'aime bien
filer des cas là de quoi tu penses que
j'oublierai clément ouais mais j'aime
fils et décale suite les autres les
élites et de moi-même sur impression que
j'ai contrôlé à tour si on regarde tout
contrôler tes cage tout contrôle là tu
verras jamais je remets mon cavalier
tâches demandées 3 je t'échange en
dessin il faut lutter en d4
je retiens à deux jeux la tour ronde et
2,3 g 2e c'est de taper pions et je suis
très heureux je vois plein de portes et
je joue très mal quand j'ai une qualité
de plus parce que je suis en pls des
pièces séminaire fâche du piaf ou non
mais c'est une vérité qui handicaperait
bon mais genre car il est des deux s'est
largement coup dans mon règne
c'est pour tenter de jouer bien quoi et
ça parce que tours à huit ce que touré
vite c'est plus pour faire deux tours
vite ça je sais pas
je suis sûr que c'est encore maxime dans
le chat il va te dire qu'il y avait de
très intéressant et la pression ça ça
apparaît étant même truc si on bouge on
se prend le foie jeux 3d 3
non mais quel est ce que je la prendrai
peut la laisser en disant tiens tu ne
développe pas tu es mal quoi alors dit
la prend pas et ça y est ou presque en
face à ces sorties source dans l'autre
non mais cette fois je leurs lacunes
souvenirs là dessus la défense
c'est lors de coups et c'est être plus
précis la fois je crois peut-être mieux
bref 5 qui est des docks est bon d'avoir
gardé d'attaquer doit alors dit que
propose ce n'est pas évident d'y penser
mais en fait une fois que tu le vois tu
ne dis pas qu'on va regarder tout le
plus direct il faut prendre
tu auras tu refuses les échanges jcct en
cavalier prendre je trouve bien ça pour
doubler mes proches réparer car tu vas
je vais venir en d3 pour couvrir mon
pions tu as tu fait rage et de porter
des heures et ça je suis d'accord il dit
en être aujourd'hui je sais pas trop si
l'on sache pourquoi je suis pas venu ici
h4 tendance
mais je comprends que c'est peut-être
nul mais en fait pour moi c'est soit
avec les blancs je vais pouvoir
progresser trouver un plan soit ça va
être nul mais je me sens tellement
prendre 0 rizki et avoir peut-être une
possibilité parce que s'ils gagnent un
pion encore là c'est fini
ah bah oui on va donner encore mais j'ai
mal à voir qu'on va progresser en tout
cas pourquoi pas à pas vers 5h
intéressante a priori même le coup
peut-être pour jeu pour le bien
d'ailleurs si duda réfléchi qui concerne
le coup ouais parce que t'as pas trop de
terrain tu veux pas ça tu fais ça tu te
dis moi je veux tu files la cale de
proposer ce trophée
puisque tu as le cavalier qui va rester
tout à la fin on va de l'ordi moyens et
tu dis ça s'apprend pas direct en fait
c'est à dire venir ici t'embêter c'est
vrai que ça lui en vis-à-vis bref trois
ans soit pas content tu dois ce qui te
bouffe la torture prend comme ça parce
que vous prendrez 5 ses tours troyes
c'est mauvais bah mauvais c'est un grand
mot mais on l'a déjà regarder ça en fait
il ya du jeu prénom après mauvais nom
reste un grand mot mais pas forcément
moins bien que les blancs mais il ya
suffisamment de confrontation dans le
fret qui a aidé de jouer apparemment
d'affréteur thunder hockey intéressant
du coup je suis content parce que
c'était mon feeling aussi voir cardiaque
juste pour france préconise de réfléchir
un peu les tours 8 qui a lieu ce
week-end c'est sûr que si mais pour les
plans sans fait qu'il valait soit là bas
oui la f3 l'option je pense qu'il va la
gagner carrière prend et défend tout du
bol il est un peuple au nombre et en
dehors du fait que j'espère que ce soit
fait d'os qui gagne pas ce que je serais
type entre eux
enfin flou plus aux candidats mais en
vrai sur le temps à kariat vraiment très
gros coup je ne connais pas mais
un joueur tu vois qui a l'habitude de
faire les gros tournois seront temple a
pas trop vus ça me ferait peur pour lui
hamon est heureuse sur leur maître le
mec en fait mais moi je le connais un
peu choquant et sa femme
c'est vrai rien je vais mieux sa femme
que lui avait c'est vrai que même ces
assises tu sais l'origine peut rien sans
que c'est vrai qu'il faut au moins six
mois c'est moins fatigant de fonds ne
s'y est pas qu en fait vraiment et que
voit le juge l'a connue c'est pourquoi
on se demande bien quand lille a w
et c'est vrai qu'on veut aller à gerland
sur cette chaîne dédiée je connais tel
fille oui là on se serait bien de quoi
tu dis vous je le connais de par sa
femme
mais
mais oui non du coup sa fin mais sympa
alors ça se passe comment pour les
candidats c'est magnus va en finale
alors du coup magnus pourraient être
qualifiés aux candidats savent que s'ils
perdent ce match pour le titre de
champion du monde
voilà de basse il pourrait pas jouer aux
conditions que le défendre merci jeunes
confiés aux finales de la coupe du monde
du coup il aura sa face aux corridas si
jamais c'est un genre de sécurité fab
normes admises depuis d'autres raisons
il a bien raison de jouer c'est enfin
sandra qualificatifs et donc ils
essayent de se qualifier aux candidats
pour être bien sûr de les jouer en 4
défaites
c'est à vous que je le dis avec aller
jusqu'à quand il va tenir font pas
rectifié la vérité et ce sans attendre
une question me dire je sais même pas
j'ai pas lu au règlement est ce que
c'est bien car la troisième place c'est
le troisième place mais s'il va en
finale c'est le vainqueur de la
troisième place qui le truc qui paraît
logique 20 que j'aurais intuitivement
femmes on va repêcher son adversaire du
premier tour parce que peut-être
mais en fait c'est un trois
qualificatifs magnus joue on sait pas
trop pourquoi
dans cas
miles kane est candidat sera dur des
commentaires en moins et donc du repos
pour vous abbaoui ah oui ça serait bien
en fait cette règle instaurée il vient
aux candidats ils viennent les candidats
bon bah tu es champion du monde suivante
personne tranquille tu perds tu es plus
rien et je vais faire la même pour la
coupe du monde en fait est vrai qu on
s'est compliqué en fait on déconne
on prend tous les candidats en fait
baratelli mina les gens sur qui essaye
de se qualifier pour les candidats
battus sur tout le monde dit que je
gagne un jour de moins au candidat
éliminé le joueur aux muscles qu à petit
à petit au train s'ils gagnent gagne de
l'argent non sans milan m et 100 milles
pour karl scène c'est comme pour toi 10
euros enfin je sais pas peut-être même
trois ou deux ou enfin non c'est assez
rien pour lui 5000 euros c'est toujours
bien mais et jusqu'à 250 milles sur les
tournois d'un arbitre et sur internet
l'an dernier par les contrats de pub les
chairs holt vice versa c'est pas rien
mais c'est pas énorme c'est pas ça pour
boire non mais vraiment c'est effrayant
grâce à un peu veut prendre sa place
fauteuils rouges il attend donc tu es
très heureux tu arrives en finale puis
l'étude donne un thème de merde j'ai vu
ce match et ce ni coop cette année
rockstar zolder c'est jusqu'aux
demi-finales striction sa partie de
tableau de la table partie tableau de
magnus se font avoir par sa présence
mais les demi-finalistes profite de sa
présence est vraiment pour avoir de
chance c'est tellement injuste le
système de rased fin ça montre ça marche
sur la tête d'un doodle willaya deux
chatons et la qualif avec un seul
morceau et même en perdant il pourrait
de base feydeau karekin
l'isie marque son territoire ceux qui
pensaient que la pandémie avait changé
la donne pas s'y perd ce match c'est le
premier top d'un monde qui joue et hyper
direct il varie remarquée du tout car
celle ci perd ce match pour moi il est
plus champion du monde aux abats esprit
chevaleresque sains d'esprit cheval non
ce serait vous en faites comme ça mais
en fait non sur une spécialité reaper
etc du coup ses 1 300 en jeu c'est un
qualified enfin c'est soi à soi l'un sur
l'autre soit tu perds ton titre et c'est
un vrai truc soit tu perds pas ton nom
mais pas pour moi en fait c'est un colis
fire et c'est un truc comme ça en plus
on ne sait pas qui a pas une valeur de
basse et convenir pour moi gagner ça
c'est pas du tout mieux que gagner un
match kenzy quoi c'est rien c'est juste
bien le gagner mais c'est pas bon ça si
tu gagnes pas tu vas y que tu gagnes pas
ça qui gagne jamais rien autoproclamé en
mondial train on ne s'est pas créé une
sur internet ma bref dsk il ya une
compétition et la tête en lui a gagné
fera sûrement même oui moi je mets une
cantine toute façon c'est pas mon permis
aux gens pourquoi tu aimes pas manu
c'est un coin puisque dès que tu
critique le fait qu'ils jouent cette
compet ce que c'est un califat l'heure
les gens disent tu aimes pas magnus mais
moi je m'en fout en fait on fait des
beaux jours et qui vit dans le même
discours
radjah baba l'aurait même discours en
fait c'est ça le truc c'est pas une
question d'un nouveau nom c'est un bon
point mais il faudrait pas que ce soit
qualificatif
oui mais il se trouve que ces
qualificatifs web c'est le problème
vient
ouais c'est ça à l'heure il ya quasiment
raison c'est ça qui fait il pousse le
délire mais finalement lorsque le titre
était complètement privé le champagne on
était plus juste que l'actuel règlement
de la file est-ce que tu essaies 30
vraiment le numéro 2 sur la période
c'est vrai mais c'est terrible mais
c'est quasiment vraie bonne sinon
je suis sincèrement que les autres
joueurs comme ça chaque fois ils avaient
défoncé tout le monde c'est vrai j'ai
dit dans mon interview à sur russia
today que c'était probablement le plus
grand joueur de l'histoire
mais en fait c'est juste que si toi tu
écoutes que la moitié de ce que je dis
et que tu prend en compte que quand tu
dis du négatif va c'est sûr que tu vas
voir ce biais mais il trouve que j'ai
dit le contraire dans une interview
quand on m'a demandé là comme le dit fab
c'est juste qu'il joue un calife
ailleurs que je trouve ça délirant bon
bah je dis si quelqu'un d'autre le
faisait ce serait pareil et si ces
résultats sont jugés plus sévèrement
c'est parce qu'il est plus fort
forcément c'est comme si djoko y perd en
demi finale de grand chelem toute
l'année qui gagne pas un grand chêne ga
tient cette année il a pas gagné grand
chelem il en petite forme alors que s'il
ya oui c'est mon fils qui fait 4 2 me de
grands chênes tu joues rebondies raison
de haut selon bain
tu jugeras battouta temps c'est normal
nîmes à chaque fois tu passes ton temps
à lui casser du sucre sur le dos et
souhaitait sa défaite en permanence en
fait c'est complètement faux mais bon
mais après enfin sens en soi de sa
défaite que c'est du sucre c'est juste
aussi très souvent ça dans n'importe
quel sport tas un peu pour le petit
poussin bas tout le temps même raconte
un ogre au foot fait un schéma qui a
fondu petite équipe batte et condensée
utilise battre bien il faut un bon match
puis des fois qu'ils ont les imineo
voilà en face
en général c'est toujours content et la
petite incertitude du sport et donc
comme la sacem et les favoris contre 12
dates je peux dire c'est beau si on
arrive à le battre s'il perd by père
c'est ça mais comme la carène moustaki
badjoko quoi tu diable c'est vous pour
que renault mais c'est ça c'était du mal
à djoko en soit ils perdent ou un mec
qui bat nadal à roland tu [ __ ] bravo
il a battu nadal à roland mais ben
hassine allez y ait eu des abattoirs où
il a gagné 13 fois fantastique aussi
enfin les deux mecs me demande et je
leur réponds que si mon dieu car celle
du bas je pensais plus grands joueurs de
l'histoire on n'a jamais aussi bien joué
donc c'est ce que je pense mais c'est
vrai ce pack voilà quand tu comptes d'où
doit juste ya une petite surprise vous
avez qui arrive machin enfin juste le
mec est numéro un mondial depuis dix ans
face comme pau gatcha au tour de france
hurlent à caen et se désape de montage
je tiens à ce que bing ne garde plus
prendre une étape le mettre en danger
parfait sinon il peut gagner 10 tours de
france d'affilée sera la plus grosse
crise de tous les temps et fait un bravo
à lui mais tu as envie pendant que tu
vis le truc des fautes un petit truc
mais la certitude et ses eaux du coup de
prix la qualité et il attaque le footsal
roncq regarder on s'attend à foulon et
en plus dans les autres cool que j'ai
dit fin même souvent fait que j'ai
appris à jouer le kart bad aussi bien en
m'inspirant des parties de carl scène
enfin j talmont liens de carlson aussi
mais bon auto progrès champion du monde
s'était pas très gentil d'un moquer mais
si vous prenez du second degré dans des
phrases pour du troll du courant tandis
que maxime a des absences c'est pas très
gentil non plus enfin ayant fait vous
n'êtes pas être content dont il ya des
blagues et tout et vous croire que c'est
que du premier degré pendant huit heures
d'affilée non mais
pensez vraiment qu'on pense que pâques
est plus fort que mvl parce qu'il est en
quarts de finale rien du coup faut tout
prendre au premier degré aussi mais bon
c'est terrible mais bon on veut du
suspense dans le sport non mais là en
plus du coup c'est vrai que pour baky
j'étais vraiment déçu qu'il joue contre
carleton ce que tu dis vraiment en
quarts de finale d'avoir par georges
entre elles pas plutôt sur la chambre
cloud chose n'était pas gagné d'avancé
mais tu as plus de chances
nice baron qui jouait le truc que je
pensais de talent mais tu as chili
maxime je pense qu'il aurait joué pas
mal mais ça c'est le même style on est
aussi qu'on les uns que les autres
séries mais c'est donc ceci le dynamique
qu'a vécu le machin et tuba pourquoi tu
aimes bien lâché décale ce que tu dis
oui je vais tactiquement avec mes pièces
mineurs votre amour et après je vais
gagner avion je vais pousser peut-être
sans un bon coup de coeur on nous
demande quels sont les conventions pour
du tabac en vérité une pièce plus de
pions c'est pas des compensations c'est
égalité matérielle c'est 5 points contre
cinq points c'est même peut-être les
blancs qui sont un peu mieux
matériellement un jour jouer ça en fait
c'est bien pour les banques garder une
tour pas changer ce que ça c'est une
règle on peut vouloir dire on a déjà dit
plusieurs fois mais quand tu es de bonne
qualité en fait les noirs ils ont deux
tours les biens se montrent qu'une en
cas des changes pour les blancs il ya
une espèce de pièces qui aura disparu il
faudrait plus de tours donc n'aurait
plus jamais lutté sur les colonnes ou
sur les rangées etc
alors tant que là tu aurais envie elle
peut faire des trucs donc un peu
amoindrir l'impact d'une tour adverse
donc c'est mieux de la garder en vie
plutôt qu'accepter cet échange si
possible maj amiens tourbe est un fou et
c'est pour béranger cinq monts fawcett
tutoie vous rangez 5 bouffe en fait
c'est pas très fière d'avoir perdu ce
temps là on fait ça tu feras ton retour
tu ton plein et cavalières 3 qui est un
fait et du coup je passe par f3 déjà
doublé mais double m
faire cuire 3 devenant d'évaluer cinq
ans je bouffe bouffe mais bon tu assez
dur a tenu enfin c'est compliqué dans
son dos bien malheureusement ici à
tanger chiarelli détroit aussi au pire
je qualité 3 je suis pas mal enfin je
veux roi y croire de rodez d'euros f2
après j'aime être l'option h4 puis je te
prendre en d5 où j'espère cavaliers 500
noms des cinq frères roy b3e les rois b3
b4 reprend ses cinq voyages et des plans
quand même en fait je défends tout il
peut rien m'arriver genre de trucs
peut-être que rien dans ce cas ci gagne
enfin malheureusement fait comme le fait
c'est que là j'ai un double biais pour
tout ah bon c'est déjà j'aime bien les
surprises mais en plus s'ils gagnent
dans mon style votre à 10 ou 15 jours et
à montfa c'est le paroxysme de ce que je
veux faire c'est tous les coups que
j'aime ce style que j'aime et c'est cool
donc il se trouve que je serai
doublement heureux d'une victoire de
duda mais là c'est aussi parce que
j'aime bien ces finales non mais là elle
aurait fait une belle partie
mais du coup il faudrait passer à la
machine cie f5 c'est la faute ici
parfois je crois mais ça fera mathieu
corner 3 oui on peut faire de la turbine
de meylan peux pas vous dire comme ça
pendant est-ce que ça c'était pas
finalement le truc à faire absolument
après je ne sais pas à vendre à des
tournois online mais on a les deux pour
la toile à et met ça en fait du monde
seul nom wii va faire food et de cavale
il faut des deux ont su un peu peut-être
tff un corner tôt pour analyser
j'en ai c'est possible 13,5 ce truc ils
font 4 fossat de jouer mais avril un
vrai dire si on regarde le scénario des
deux parties est ce que mon là de toute
façon c'est soit tout à soi nul
franchement duda sur les deux parties il
a mieux joué que 40 scènes un peu mieux
alors après aux échecs le truc c'est
qu'il faut vraiment faire une diplomate
elle point c'est dur il ya une porte
mais c'est pour moi c'est plus tout à
coup j'ai un peu plus fort sur ce match
après les échecs c'est un jeu où
l'attendait donc vrai je pense pas qu'il
a gagné personnellement je pense que
magnus ci va la tenir mais cette frange
et 5 peut-être bon c'est trois faux
complots en béton qui prend un pion de
le plus fou au passage donc c'est cool
mais tout ça il a vraiment progressé
c'est bizarre ce qu'il était
complètement fort en norvège or forme en
norvège on voudrait en fait sont des
faux pour ce match d'ouverture mais si
la page ou un grande chez ce tour paris
où qu ils étaient comme étant au bois
aussi y'a pas longtemps j'ai donc du
coup tu dis bon il a pas bosser il est
aubois machin est tous humains issus
mais là tout d'un coup tu as
l'impression qu'il a fait un job faut
voir s'ils continuent dans le temps ce
peugeot cède sa forme ou le format comme
ça qu'il adore je sais pas bien dans les
grands prix il a fait une finale lacombe
choc à la fois qu'elle est grand prix
donc c'est aussi un format qui convient
bien
je sais pas pourquoi c'est devenu un
fritz quatre sujets plus petite ampleur
depuis sa non mais
dire que même s'ils se qualifient pas ou
quoi c'est que si tu prends tout le
tournoi plus ce match en langue sur karl
scène tu dis je vous tapez 10 large
sourire juste l'autre match ok computer
enfin j'ai cinq mois qu'il veut garder
le principe et donc on s'attend à kg 6
parce que c'est un champion on est
toujours le f3 emploi ou l'ordi prise
c'est bien parce que j'assure cavaliers
pranger mais on peut prendre et prendre
et sinon on fera la f3 quand même donc
ok en gros carrés kinky et j'ai si cette
option est pas prenable et donc il
faudrait remettre le caviar quatre ans
cadets champions bien le blindé et
embêter son adversaire peut-être sinon
prendre et pousser les pions et c'est
win a atteint yakine plutôt mieux on
verra alors christophe complexe complexe
même les deux parties doit c'est dur de
savoir ce qui va se passer
en fait ça peut faire deux gains blank
de nu je pense à ces documents c'est
l'embellie au précariat keynes une
connerie tu persistes est un peu plus
quoi on ne va pas perdre de si beaux si
ce sera très bien mais je veux dire
c'est pas une potion sur route
j'aimerais arriver c'est encore ouvert
aux conneries quoi bon jeu sur un tir et
pranger 5e france a déjà été dit mais ce
serait pratique l'art un petit échiquier
dans un coin avec la position en cours
on l'a pas fait on a décidé de le faire
comme ça ce qui se passe pas grand chose
déjà on te regarde et de suivre la
partie on voit en fait que l'échiquier
il est un peu parce télé oui quand on
analyse sur son jouet un coup mais c'est
pas changé les subtiles faux après on
revient mais non mais c'est vrai que si
tu sais pas pour la peine
c'est pas facile du coup pour pas avoir
trop d'information partout et que les
gens font le signe que film à l'été
les gens du coup c'est plus qu'un rêve
c'était devenu trop complexe
du coup on a décidé de garder ce truc là
avec des choses comme un kiosque hommes
et le l'échiquier passe teulet et après
on va voir ce qui va jouer si on est
trop confuse pour à 8 ans a pas beaucoup
ouais tour d un mois je ne serais jamais
allé blanc s'assassiner de kiev qui est
très bien la touriste y est les
coulonneux des fonds b de l'élite les
invasions l'aurait presse bar et le
cavalier s'il l'a ramené sur un endroit
sûr des droits ici pour rebondir là ou
là si on échange suis là et en d3 comme
dans les cars bad en fait c'est une
structure carlsbad y réfléchit oui mais
c'est face en est une avec le pion c'en
est une sans en être une méta pioncer 6
faible que tu vas l'établé à taper tu
protèges b2 talent à cazaux 5
donc là on s'est tournés invasif et tout
reprend à 8 me contre 105 on prend un
jeudi noir peuvent aussi favoriser
toujours aussi nul autour des mains
c'est logique
mais très heureux de la question c'est
carcela pour se qualifier s'affronter ni
même en quelque sorte cette [ __ ] de
truie malheureusement ces quatre doigts
de faire échanger tu vas steak lui tout
seul lui tout seul
ils sont les tournois vont se régaler
parce que tu as travaillé sur des
colonnes ouvertes vont pouvoir doubler
en plus des pions sur cases noires temps
fou à l'aider à défendre sa peu de
chance c'est bizarre que l'ardiden pas
grand chose moi je viendrai plus simple
bah c'est pas si c'est un message qui va
pour tourner non mais t'es peut-être que
c'est très chiant en pratique
peut-être l'oreille gérant d'esi
colmater tu progresses plus en fait
revoir peut-être pas le temps d'armer le
rang b 4 peut-être pas le temps en fait
ça doit aller pour un magnus ouais ouais
non bien sûr mais c'est un peu chiant
pratique pour jouer duda je pense qu'il
a fait tourner un jeu signé ces matchs
gagnants des trois places et france 5 et
b4 joie c'était l'idée que j'avais des
débuts agités sûr que maxime
interviendrait en ma faveur sur
sacrifice de qualité en fait j'avais le
truc de base de d'aimer faire ça après
je regardais masse deux parties de
maxime où il le fait et du coup j'ai vu
que j'adore maintenant je me sens très à
l'aise aux maximes dégoûté oui si un tel
qu'on a eue ce plan j'ai vraiment
beaucoup régressé ces derniers temps
absence de quoi enfin si l'on peut plus
quoi ici comment es-tu fait de si
faibles pour le même plan qu'un tel
concours
mais leurs biens le plan détrompe-toi
fabien depuis qu'il a dit ça beaucoup
perdure nous voilà donc le truc pour la
boîte à l'heure c'était sa terreur à
mener pour aller ici donc on s'y fait
ici sont passés par là ça il veut nous
échanger la tour on n'a pas très envie
alors nommé cheikh bara fut le tour huit
ou quoi convaincu grave il est mieux
placé pour aller là bas au cas où un
jour mais je vais le mettre en c2 du gie
afer roi detroit alors je me prends la
case aj tf6 votre trading
maintenant je me demande s'il fait froid
ces deux et c'est peut-être
l'amener l'inconnu c'était le plan
maximaliste ce que j'aime si j'ai quitté
trois rois b3 je me sens bien mais bon
est-ce qu'on peut y arriver
[Musique]
j'adore le couple indiqué alléger un f4
je prends à les infiltrer
oui mais bien du coup sûr attendre je
m'en fous complètement fou qu'on
l'attend je suis canadien c'est plutôt
du côté avec les bleus en fait tu crains
rien mais toro bien je fais qu'il y
avait des choix quand même du parc
férois f8 dix ans et là je peux
peut-être prendre déjà prendre à venir
réuni 1 et fait tour à tour à deux par
loin qui a aidé 3 tu défends ton truc
ton va revenir
non mais c'est sûr que je ferai ça près
ce que je gagne ou pas j'en tire sur un
truc mais je crois que jusqu'à b6
rafraîchir bbc jeu ok donc qui veut
cavaliers c4 en fait donc faux cavalier
a fini puis veut éviter ce truc à tout
jamais maintenant fo cavaliers f3 ici
c'est sûr ça ce qui est 6-4 tu prends et
cabello ce week end 3 c'est sûr à 100%
en cavale est très mal placé ici ou tour
e 1 en fait il y meurt et pour l'instant
ils bougent sonnerie blocs seul mais il
veut qu avait laissé quatre fous prend
froid et du coup t'as pas le temps d'un
coup une erreur non mais la question en
fait c'est ce que tu as toujours un
cahier ses quatre champions prend pour
cinq tours à 2 aïe aïe f6 donc t'as pas
neutre en ce sens et vous fait celui et
lui mais si j'ai pas j'ai pas donc du
coup ça veut dire que je vois qu'ils
avaient des f3 sur khalid sekkat g bubka
a lieu cinq et j'attaque lui qui
protégera lui laissons woerth au fbi 8
quand même jeu
m je proteste sur géométrie d' je tiens
ça de battre m je fais retour 3g deux
tours f3 cavaliers aux cinq options je
me sens tellement bien cette position là
ouais je voudrais je virevolte la
jugeait volta là je sans toi il joue
enfin admis sans puce dans cette
position elle est donc étroite un paquet
c4 ordi danko à tours fc itt de 5 jours
à cet arrêt qui est des trois de plus de
kaïs et 4 auquel j'ai pas tous rentrer
qui est des deux d'ancrage et 2005
toujours plus possible catherine attend
bon en fait en vrai tu fais quoi ta
c'est quoi tes coups papa tu auras 2 tu
peux pas vraiment à les doubler parce
que tu vas te prendre ça un jour et
mekhout c'est juste h4 bref 3g quatre
fois j'irai quoi je monte fait pourquoi
tu joues devant affaires sociales et
attendre oui mais bon je vais monter la
tête après je rêve 3g 4 h 5
j'ai poussé g5 dans la gueule puis h61
monnaie je vais partir pour prix ce qui
a valu aux cinq et trois d'avancé de
houphouet moi j'aurais l'impression
d'être à deux doigts je gagne au passage
sur la fin j'étais complètement gagnant
j'ai toutes les cases blanches et les
cases noires tweakers chez peyriac bombe
à qui je suis ce qu'on avait dit non
mais si père ça ce sera un gros coup au
moral un moral est dans un mauvais soir
et non diffusés tout au toby flood 3 il
pas bien même aimons ce serait quand
même un gros coup au moral d'être out
pris peur de par duda qui est censé
censé être le point faible c'est à dire
qu'il a progressé de près par abe
sneijder il ajoute louis jouer du coup
jusqu'à la ceni c'est un excellent
joueur de finale n'est pas forcément un
excellent défenseur
soukhoumi débat qui en a rarement
tellement pris comment choisit tout ch4
tous ok f4 je sais pas pourquoi c'est
souvent au final le pion à ce qu'on en
voit plus que le pion f ça te garde plus
de sécurité sur la deuxième angie moins
de 15 en fait ouais je touche f8 on peut
venir sur la colonne heures entre le 2 3
des trucs comme ça
champion f2 avec la tour d2
ouais ça flatte ce qui a été dit quand
tu bouges le curage tu ne lâches qu'une
case quand tu veux je veux plus bref
c'est à dire de la lâche même pas vu que
la droite est déjà en général quand tu
pousses ayache tu l'as eu une casse de
moins quand tu pousses un autre pion
donc le vainqueur de la coupe du monde
affrontera ça redonne complètement
différent le vainqueur un buzz hop hop
hop hop hop scherwey rencontre le
vainqueur du dernier geste et du coup
après vraiment sarr qui est le meilleur
comment le clash des rois quoi ça serait
beaucoup oui on va se préparer contre le
saumon dette inquiète face à caen là je
m'étends récupère 2 va pas vraiment
parce qu'en fait quand le pion à vence
tu sais que tu peux les gagner à
n'importe quel moment mais tu peux plus
reculer
ouais en fait ce que tu a lâché tu vas
vraiment lâche à tout jamais c'est
irrévocable irréversible
l'apparence action f7 non ça ça marche
tellement jamais je sais pas pourquoi
faire il ya aucune idée en battant s'il
ne reste qu'un public soit est fou hbf
ça suffit qu'un pion un pion à roybon
bref que h en non mais karl scène je le
voyais pas du tout est en difficulté
contre tout ça en fait j'en longue
là ces petites difficultés après
complexe g parrainant la turbine est
elle là s'inquiète pas du tout mais je
ne suis pas trop long + 0 40 mais si
elle comprend vraiment quelque chose de
la merde c'est un signe syrien de direct
après c'est plus long terme pour moi
d'avoir un truc qu on avait des
positions l'ena en fait on plus trop de
plans les attentes doivent défendre les
blancs essayer de progresser palix soit
suffisant pour l'emporter mais en tout
cas pénible et c'est après avoir craqué
noah on en voudrait on faire tourner
l'affairé sera pas bougé le truc en fait
de la sécu pions des pas prenable ce
qu'ont expliqué tout à l'heure en cas d'
échange pourra reprendre le cavalier un
cadeau ici intouchables grâce à ce pion
le défend il ya les présentations
auxquelles j'ai cinq donc tout va bien
le qu'areva blindes espion il y en
aurait aujourd'hui f3 pour dégager suis
là peut-être faire du e7 jarny estate de
prostate à un moment où si
éventuellement il ya le fouquet pas
terrible ce turc s blanc je vais sur f3
sauce une idée dont toutes les choses qu
et ça fait qu'il est plutôt pas mal car
yakine mais n'en bouge pas trop se fait
de cf qui essaie de trouver quoi faire
et en vrai ça pourrait être quasiment
entre guillemets fin du fin du tournoi
oui et non mais en fait si ta carrière
doute à et et karine qui gagne
aujourd'hui en gros fin de l'enjeu du
tournoi après il y aura une finale mais
je veux dire par là que tu auras les tu
peux dès ce soir alors que visuellement
tu dis bon ça va durer jusqu'à vendredi
mais en fait ce soir tu pourrait déjà
avoir les deux qualifiés j'aime bien
deux jours pour les candidats qui
rejoignent en de 9 et le perdant du
match
ouais ouais 1408 n'est pas encore à 7
sur 7 mai
complexe très complexe
on suit un peu on attend quoi
il fume un genre mètres de là d'affilée
lapping bim tu vas faire une chouette de
pau z
ouais je suis une pause après une petite
pause j'aurais une deuxième cuba ce sont
un peu des pubs de partout là ça
t'embête pas il a joué tous un rôle à
quel coût de merde ces cavaliers c4 et
envoie y aura pas de poussettes fab gars
fed
c'est dommage de ne pas avoir vu le
cavalier 3 il a dû rater quelque chose
après
c'est un peu bizarre parce que toute
façon on ne veut pas échangé tourisme et
sur une colonne ouverte à tous les cas
et les c4 nous gêner [ __ ] en pions
prend peut-être tour cette tourbe et 8
pour ses sets
donc on les deux tours prend ses six as
et surtour ses 8
y'a pas toi rêve ça tient si c'est toi
prends prise il n'a pas le temps de tout
à fait bizarre second tour là j'ai pas
du tout aimé cavalière trump et kovalev
3 me paraissait bien au-dessus ce que ça
prémunissait contre le plan cavalli c4
s'est replacé le cavalier vers détroit
étonnant en fait c'est le coût de leur
dit qu'ils avaient froide c'était aussi
mon savait était aussi mon premier
réflexe sans regarder la turbine du coût
et du coup ça m'étonne il a dû voir
quelque chose sur cavalière 3 qui le
gênait
il doit vouloir peut-être tours 2 t'es
tu veux quelque chose comme ça menace
cavale et f6 mais la paca et des six ici
à toi toi qui es c4 ce qui va calmer
cavaliers à quatre ils le voient retour
cette étape est sûre f7 qui avait prouvé
deux prises à vii mais qui avait laissé
quatre en fait ça bloque le fou c'est
pas une
il doit avoir une idée sur kelly c
quatre et nous vu qu'on a la turbine est
on voit que ça marche pas mais on sait
pas pourquoi parents c'est parce qu'il a
raté la magnus à jouer je suis sûr que
ses qualités 4g pas pu voir le coup mais
c'est sûr que ces cavaliers ckt il ya un
truc qui nous a échappé
ouais jouer duda il a raté quelque chose
et là c'est magnus qui va jouer qui va
presser bizarre cette faute quand même
qui avait l'air froid était tellement
logique suis très étonné wen en magnus
atteint en mai je sais pas j'ai pas
trouvé le niveau de magnus ouf mais sur
parti mais ouais j'ai jugé pas le
cavalier f3 m'a échappé mais qu'ils
sachent en quad qui est des singles en
fête surprise priest a pu la case d3
pour le cavalier pour défendre b2 est à
tourbes et huit tours à deux tours prend
b2 donc ça change beaucoup de choses ce
pur ans et 4 ça fixe l'option b c'est
étrange ce tourer femme qui va revenir
mais il trouve ça très étrange aussi
m'expliquer et c4 quasi tempo mais tu
vois je pense que les cadences sont pas
assez longues fab il n'a pas eu assez de
temps pour être précis sur le cavaliere
trois gros tournages auront peut-être
dès le 10e coup maggiori ajournement 20e
il va mettre la turbo t il aux réfugiés
avoir le coeur et les trois ou quatre
mais c'est étonnant tour un vraiment du
goût issue à bah oui je suis
complètement là et c'est fou ce faire
sur un de tes idées deuxième lecture que
c'est quand même la ligne mail tu
commences fille qui habite ici une
chance qu'ils veuillent venu inscrire 4
j'arrive c'est comme une grosse erreur
tour là non
très étrange il doit y avoir une raison
il le dira en conférence de presse où
couraient on pourra comprendre la
première vue a passé vraiment une erreur
très conséquente kf3 c'est quand même le
coup logique on moi j'ai pensé vraiment
sans regarder l'ordi pour cavaler fin
assez logique mais avec valence et car
c'est ça en fait un en gros c'est encore
le coup d'avant il fait ça bien de se
barrer donc il veut venir se mettre là
pour bloquer le four vous savez plus de
problèmes là-bas la tour reprend sa
liberté
et puis pression sur la base la chaîne
de pion dans gauc he et donc disais
ouais c'est vrai que sur ça ça lui peut
débarquer ont fait une petite attaque
double r et surtout l'idée quand on
prend lui on va dire ça c'est comme en
défense a donc tout va très bien car il
ya quatre l'a embêté bon ok tu fais ça
depuis longtemps mais c'est 5 c'est
peut-être ça qui l'ont été pour des deux
et c'est pas moi je sais pas si on fait
ça en fait on écoute je vois elle fait
tour d2 pour voir et c5 et prendre
peut-être avant alors dit tu dis qu'ils
avalent ie5 ouais c'est ça qui a fait
peur c'est sûr
ce que cinq c4 et pas forcément content
content
en fait il faut faire le tour et
repartir maman mais ça tu peux mal jugé
oui mais c'est pas con le port de
nuisement phase récente des tours 1 du
ca empêcher qu'un rallye à 4 mais tu te
rend sa bombe de tête qui va vouloir
nous faire un truc la main et se dire ok
je vais rater ça je pression là-dessus
on va voir non mais ça explique les
rares parce que sinon c'était trop
bizarre hein en fait à vrai dire une
fois que tu as compris ça tu comprends
prix il a fait la faute face et bête
quand même ce qu'à ce niveau là tu es
censé pas faire ce genre d'erreur mais
au moins on la comprend oui pour les
nuls coup n'est pas cette chance
ouais non mais c'est sa ré masse fait
longtemps fait que je milite pour les 15
ans quand même curieux viennent plus aux
traditions des échecs ces deux heures
vingt coups du croit même foutu une
pendule ouais non ça et tu veux parler
de l'époque mais peut-être que je vais
sans point dur est le genre voyage en
bateau longtemps les mains je sens pont
du leu ouais c'est vrai que c'est plus
tradition c'est plus tradition que je
avec pendule quoi peut-être si vous une
semaine de macapa jouer tu dis bon quand
même faut un petit peu de bouger n'a
mais sans elle s'en trouva trop de
pression à une semaine très mal ça pas
sûr qu'il trouvera le meilleur coup vous
donc du coup ils bouffent non
avant l'invention de l'or là j'aurai je
pense que l'invention de levallois
j'avais vraiment de dénaturer les échecs
c'est bien je me semble l'avoir vu faire
grossir quatre pions grand et ça peu
buggé alors je dois bien sont très
énervés a pendu le mot près je suis pour
le jeu sans pendule et moi aussi je
pourrais même le bruit c'est complexe
il a vraiment mal joué en fait tout ça
c'est bon on l'encensé en fait non il
restait tout ceci n'est rien progresser
du tout sûr et même plus de gagner
samantha niveau du groupe histoire ça
bouge avec des cadrans solaires
il te reste plus que deux heures de
soleil certes sur ton car très attention
parce vous mais sur l'échiquier voir
s'il a joué son coup et d'autres calmes
être un peu à l'affût ouais mais alors
là attention pouvoir trouver n'importe
quoi oui cardiaque et en physique aux
acariens corps bien fait quoi l'autre la
poussée des 4 etc lennar et une allonge
et cinq noms d un hayon d'éviter les
forêts des cas d'option
pas encore car
à quoi peut pas avoir la caméra sur
magnus n'ont à priori c'était le truc un
pan du jour pourtant ouais on ne veut
pas de celle mise en avant c'est
l'événement de demi-finale magnus à
celui qui ramène toute la hype je peux
essayer dans ce tout officiel c'est
qu'il ya vraiment des gens car les
vidéos youtube juste pour voir le salut
fabre ils sont en pause chaise comme
lassé pause tandis que seulement dans
les pubs et two way comme nous mais
voilà il a pris ans et iv et v prend et
bien de le faire d'ailleurs donc
dalleau j'ai croisé quelqu'un qui me
fait un salut femme dort pas juste un
salut face à l'ufa voilà exactement 10
commente ouais bah oui ambühl s
d'envoyer un petit peu je faisais du
pédalo c'est là je peux aller coiffer
5h30 cela elle s'est dite tchatche com
tu as là elle s'est dite à ses
directives de faire des photos si on
voit dans la rive bah oui enfin et
cavalières trop maintenant contresens
par mais ok du coup il se rapatrie sur
l'idée de base vers l'asie d'anciens
jeux l'attaqué sur la sof normalement
les noirs ils vont arriver à venir en
masse attaqué lui avant que kelly
prennent l'option il va lui manquer
juste un temps après peut-être qu'il
envie de faire sauter ces deux là quitte
à perdre 3-0 keita songe près nulle
parce que option de plus ces nuisibles
dans la même aile et voilà et que voilà
donc voilà je pense que l'audace résigne
se résigne à se dire vas-y on bouffe
tout on fait nul
ma chérie tu vas
contresens à vrai dire le quai b side
cars chaîne du coup pas mal je serai que
cette idée là était pas comme quoi pour
jeter ça et échanger des pions et ouvert
des trucs pour les tours etc
non
ça va faire drôle ça va faire face à
faire tourbe et huit cavaliers 5 tomber
deux c4 ces deux tours trois tours à 2
oui tu as tu fait 3,3 attendu qu'il
parte pour un retour à trois ans ouais
fait cavaler à 4,5 pour à 3 3 tu prends
un truc qui te prend ces trois des
changes
bon ça tu vas faire nul je vais me
laisser se fiancer complètement droits
sachant bien qu'ils avaient la f4 et
attend dès que ton roth et bien quoi
mais bon en d'ailleurs ce n'est même pas
obligé de filles et tonton tu es bon tu
peux investir et seniors ouais ouais le
partiparti sympa duda qui a peut-être
raté poussette ou pas mais oui nous
parlement faisant 86 semblait pas le
coup le plus inspiré et donc
rino des quatre de ces dossiers c'était
de la merde on a presque eu d'après 6/10
+2 plus générale on se retrouve là la
position ça donne l'impression que tu
sais c'est le genre de plus de celles
ordi qui défend comme un fou et des
queues à plus 2 mais en fait ça va être
la suite en trois mois mais surtout
keeper des le fougueux pour 832 canet
mais ça semblait tu te fais défoncer
quoi je sais pas exactement
concrètement comment m6 aguicheur de
penser qu'à valider deux là ici en 2005
pour ses cahiers des dockers en ckd
parquet deux peut-être bien défendre là
tu te mets un peu non des êtres la tour
il va être sur des trucs je sais pas tu
as tu réussi c'est tous réussissent
aussi fort ici c'est aussi une option
j'aime bien toi aussi tu as tout revient
là du coup tu fait qu'il y ait des 2,6
et l'autre lui dans l'air mais nous fait
plaisir quand il s'arrêtera qu'à rio 5 a
pris en plus le faire tout au plus pour
valeo 5 et poncé quatre tours f3 fin ça
ça va tu fais ce que tu veux et il
s'écoule donc oui non a priori un petit
coup de tourner la salers logique après
ça pourrait être un tour à 2 d'abord je
sais pas lire debout qui va choisir mais
attaquer b2 qui maintenant est une cible
atteignable assez facilement via deux
pièces
ouais ça devrait faire draw et partir en
départage demain feydeau cf qui sera
supporters de my own way mais pour jouer
les candidats j'étais lui en fait je
vous préparez déjà à fond demain contre
tout à hawaï puis sinon si on n'a jamais
rien ne doit faire gagner un jour de
prépa en fait ce que karlsson a pris
sens inverse a pour un nul peut pas
vraiment compter qu'il a bien joué
duda et une imprécision à un moment
personne prend 12 ha pour un nul en fait
je veux dire tu sais que le mec qui
calcule bien qu'il est bon et saufs
laddh suis vraiment très faible ah non
c'est un excellent joueur bientôt 135 e
les amis jeu font les voix matar est
déjà chaude fait chaud d'ailleurs un
petit peu un fin je sais pas on fait
moins chaud qui lui fait wars d'habitude
tu penses que la partie va bientôt se
terminer en fait un papa
temps juste un peu de route fable mais
oui mais pas beaucoup non c'est quoi
c'est une heure et quart c'est bon tu
peux regarder mais visuellement à 1h15
entre 1h et 1h30 avait été bien gardé
je suis juste là j'étais très heureux
hier soir tu vas tu
d'ailleurs c'est ce que je regardais par
la fenêtre je regarde et je sens comment
le match contre lorient ce week end a
déjà très importante quoi pour le
maintien ça va déjà directement mais qui
font ce qu est favori quand même pas pas
sûr mais pourquoi pas fatalement on an
dernier c'était déjà le prix match de la
saison saint thélo rien gagné 2 0 déjà
j'étais très inquiet bon ok on sait pas
on verra
voilà je crois qu'on est pire que l'an
dernier en fait ce qui est dur mais
écoute on va voir mais tu te sens plus
favoris ou pas cinquante ou cent favori
mais pas beaucoup
j'avais qu'à lorient a bien fini sa
saison sont maintenus déjà c'est pas mal
et c'est les merlus on est d'axer les
merlus ont perdu non plus d'un mais qui
tire bien les coups francs khazri merde
mais s'appelle l'orienter puisqu'on va
l'orienter et c'est une sorte de juninho
au moins bon dans le jeu mais tomba des
coups francs et hyper d'envoi ça serait
très très peur de lui quoi surtout pas
faire de faute reconnaît enfin je serai
plus elle je dirais bon pas de tacle
dans les 40 derniers mètres mais là t'as
pas le droit précis je sais pas la jauge
mais ils sont très heureuses lancer la
campagne d'abonnements tout ça après on
a déjà un groupe d'ultras qui veut un
peu boycotter ça leur plaît pas je sais
pas trop voilà qui remet aux ficelles il
faut mieux qu'ici parce qu'en fait ils
mettent ils ont une régie qui permet une
cam grand plan sur une partie donc la
partie qui suivent du coup ils vont à
leur rythme et ils ont carrément enfin
ils ont un gars qui fait une régie vont
à leur rythme et il faut un peu tout
comme il va lui parle dans l'oreillette
le truc c'est qu'il choisit soit ils
savent sur quelques amis vont enfin
en gros voilà alors que nous on a la
gamme grand plan a envoyé appareils
énormément de choix en fait donc en vrai
nous on est sur la cam grands plans
parce que des lascars 30 face à lorient
de ces questions avait de longues années
mais elle va être très très longues les
sous et donc c'est pas le tram commence
à lorient mais tu vois c'est loin d'être
gagné d'avancé et je serai bien content
sûr gagner ce match comprennent trois
points qu'on encaisse un peu des points
début de saison en fait il est peut-être
un des rares avantages qu'on peut avoir
par rapport à d'autres équipes c'est que
on n'a pas changé l'effectif donc c'est
marrant les automatismes on avait déjà
pas l'an dernier mais et lyon tu les
auras fini roues ont valu ne sont pas
trop mal environ le top 5 sur podium
derrière il ya une surprise en fait bon
et le trophée des champions et on s'en
fout un peu bêtement mais lille a battu
paris dalil l'année je pense à exhaler
rien faire et puis paris monde donc
voilà après avons c'est un truc qui sert
à rien un trophée des champions c'est un
peu comme la coupe du monde et chaque
coffret pas en soi mais comme car celle
ci gagne ou pas quoi c'est une ligne à
ton répertoire attend au palmarès mais
pas la même chose max qui devient
champion petit enfin ils ont qui de bon
là lyon cette année ils ont recruté quoi
je sais pas trop j'ai pas trouvé
recrutement bon ils ont plu même fils de
paille mais il ya autour de dembélé
chance pas du nouveau gc nice à galtier
sait
mais c'était super bien gens très bien
mais sauf que galtier normalement il
faut un peu de temps c'est à dire aph
faut peut-être pas cherché à faire trop
bien la première année je laisse le
temps à galtier de d'intégrer le truc de
comprendre et tu laisses de trois ans et
il va te faire un truc bien normalement
et marseille mon style en l'air pas mal
non plus saliba surtout donc la gare
défenseur du monde ils vont par contre 0
but pareil qui sera complètement claqué
deux amériques en six mois il va prendre
aux ag un emprunt f4 et des sine qua non
c'est complètement foutue ornent les
douches puntos bitstream facile oui les
douches puntos c'est beau temps le mix
cameroun thomas tient très belle gamme
en fait c'est marrant parce que les
calmes et elecam même à vay qu'elle
était pour avis mais je crois qu'elle
était mieux qu'ici calme non mais
vraiment alors moi j'ai un jouet
terrible joueurs car les kings qui va
aller aux candidats avant lundi avec
maxime tu vois j'ai tout de suite son
site dans le match maxime karim j'ai dit
car yakine il m'a fait une très très
forte impression après appris que
j'avais très bien mais sur un nombre x
il a très bien joué
toutes choses près il n'était plus là
qu'on lâche la mêlée réaction d'orgueil
non mais en fait je veux pas dire à
beaucoup de choses près parce que tu es
blanc il l'a claquée à chaque fois et
comme il était mené deux fois au score
même il a claqué jarre en jean gaulin
c'était un penalty de froid à quoi sert
la communication officer pour être km/h
à 15 une question à quoi sert la
communication communication offert un
vin versés en quel sens maxime sûrement
une grève qu'on n'a pas d'auteur à
l'ouest
[Musique]
en fait je vais te dire qu'il est tout
le temps là calmes pas la réf 12h35
ça va plus j'ai hâte toi kiev le
communiqué chez nos fils heures enfin
j'ai compris donc que tu sers à cannes
sur le tapis vous changer de ministre un
putsch j'ai réussi à livrer en fait les
pas vraiment eu dans le sens où j'ai
demandé pour karim dilou il sera bien là
calmes mais en fait c'est juste parce
qu'il voulait contrecarrer akin annonce
quoique contre à galandage et réussit à
l'heure vous n'avez pas bas qui une fois
en huitièmes ouais c'est ça on avait pas
mal qui je suis complètement à l'ouest
mais un lacet terminer un pur voilà ça
soit les douches couteau à double fond
de touche ces abandons clair il s'est
levé en fait t'as plein de problèmes si
tu ramèneras d'amendé s'ils sont bloqués
les punto super f5 tôt ou tard et tu vas
te faire mater ou tu fais ça me
prendrait 5 tu prends la finale mais
croyez le 7 il faut attaque la tour d'un
côté ou de l'autre
et puis voilà époux josh une touche
d'amos mais ces efforts les plus
touchants fait un buzz très vite les
touches et bien de vie c'est ouais ouais
ouais m'enfin gars qui ne voulait finir
mais
la gagne et les prix devraient pas trop
se tromper est là c'est ce qu'on a
montré sa rétro c'est pas mal on n'a pas
choisi la bonne partie fab après notre
parti aurait pu être intéressante non
maladie relativement intéressante une
enchère s'arrête plus jouer bien on se
questionnait on savait pas enfin c'est
pas mal on met du coup le marché est
vraiment fort quand tu le joues octobre
et 800 gr tranquille quand un mâle elle
aurait vraiment pu pousser dota ouais
ouais si faisait le guet l'être mais bon
faudrait bien la fio qui a valu à cap
tout ça aussi voir ce que ça donnerait
pts mecar yaqing du couffin de tourner
enfin le ton alors encore la finale
majeure ça y va il va souffler c'est
vrai que j'ai en fait même s'ils jouent
contre man u ça en finale
les gens me dit oui une grosse finale et
tout mais je disais non ce qu'en fait ma
nuit son objectif depuis le début il va
jouer pour la gagne du temps est venu
pour ça alors que cars yakine là quand
tu gagnes tu sortiras sahel relâchement
quand c'est pas du tout la même chose
c'est pour ça que j ça peut pas être une
vraie coupe du monde de toute façon
quand les joueurs ont des objectifs
différents karekin il a déjà passé sa
finale en fait aujourd'hui un faiseur au
foot c'est winner takes it all bat et
finissantes et finissants ou s'en
fichera alors que là on fait des
finalistes a déjà gagné le droit d'être
candidat c'est pour ça qu'il faudrait
presque faire deux tournois deux coupés
puis deux qualifiés collimateur il a mis
d'accord sur deux qualifiés après bâle
iii pour gagner il faut gagner
non non juste en fait tu vas jusqu'en
finale et en fait fin du thon à merci
vous êtes qualifiés de l'autre côté
merci vous êtes qualifiés batta deux
côtés de tableau là je la joue jamais en
fait celle de la demi-finale est en
finale ça c'est vous chacun sait une
finale en fait tu sais tout merci au
revoir
pas comme étant athé ali faut il
d'ailleurs tu fais deux coupes du monde
ou sur coup le grand vainqueur
au moins il fit passer
un pour tous d'un homme parce qu'on
disait c'est que même si tous à
connaître en rouge ça disparaît montage
en une tour dans l'eau genre tu la mets
là quand ils trouvent à ces trois des
changes a battu fait nul parce que c'est
un cas découvre une tour et reste trois
pions l'itie contre la et puis tu fais
rien quoi tu mets ton cavaliers la
tuméfaction là tu bouges ton c'est nul
théoriquement donc bah voilà donc on
s'attend un scénario un peu de ce genre
sachant qu'en plus tu as pas encore
perdu tes deux pions contraint à venir
tu peux peut-être en a chez un copain
pour un ex encore plus simple pas être
plus simple que simple mais des partages
rapide c'est quand sera donné à 14h
comme tous les jours 14 heures sera un
beau match départageront rapide du dakar
scène ça peut être sympa assurent non il
est bon un peu douteux mais bon comme
d'hab ce que je vous dis qu'un seul
favori quel que soit le lay canada les
champions du monde dans toutes les
quinze ans déjà mais il n'y a pas un
gars poussée du 100% quoi
dans cette tour trois tours à d'autres
f3 et c'est ça est ce que l escrime la
finale du coupe à moi je mandera de
chasse comme l'ont fait il ya carlson tu
pense qu'il faudra faire non ah mais
c'est à quinssaines cheval match pour la
troisième place et une autre un peu de
temps en temps ou du ca pas karl scène
je suis allez peut-être sur ma chaîne ce
que tu veux que je fasse un mot de
contenu mais refaire encore sur chaise
comme l'affirmé non ils vont dire oui
oui tu ça fait beaucoup de buzz mais en
fait pour ça dans tous les cas oui mais
en fait pour moi c'est vraiment là le tu
as une petite table comme on n'a qu'à me
regarde avec plaisir les partis
aujourd'hui n'ont rien de soporifiques
dans le contenu mais hier mais
aujourd'hui c'était plus intéressant
parce que ya en fait c'est juste que de
oued de 15h vraiment à 18h30 il sait
vraiment rien passé 15h15 un peu loin et
c'était un peu long là aujourd'hui en
fait il ya tout le temps eu un peu de
failles de bon la liasse a fait une demi
heure qui a plus grand chose parce qu'il
s'est trompé
mes joueurs savent à faire une heure de
nom fait ça pas faire trois c'est ce qui
va se passer on n'était pas trop sur ça
va ce que ça avantage que cela laisse la
main tendue mais surtout il va bien
défendre là on attend de voir comment ça
se finit alors après ils ont 27 minutes
contre un peu de temps important de voir
ça en fait je vois pas dans quel monde
tu gagnes ça a l'air tellement simple
selon matthias et même pas le genre de
position tu dis avantage mais il ya
contre joue quoi ces douches puntos ça
vraiment la vidéo que je fais sur
bitstream facile à l'excellente pour
expliquer à quel point c'est gagnant
reçoit que je fais une bonne vidéo qui
convient retour ici d'où des carmes
scène donc un joli sien aussi à fabas au
6 mai mais bon si on se tape avec fable
une partie qui jouent cette position là
cavalier trois pions contre tours 2
pions et qu'ils la jouent comme hier
pendant 1h45 un fab ou pas fable si on
suit ça jusqu'à 18h30
non mais en fait l'équivalent vraiment
soir on parlera de foot oui non je sais
mais j'ai en fait si on a quasiment
suivi l'équivalent de ça
enfin pas tout à fait mais non messi
mais on a suivi l'équivalent de ça
pendant une heure trente par absorption
des cats en plus 1h45
enfin bon et on en est quand même un peu
marre quoi là aujourd'hui c'est passé
des choses et aujourd'hui le débat c'est
intéressant aussi meilleur aussi le
public était moins ne pas dire bien
moins développement des échecs en france
en général partie d'entre eux me choque
pas car c'est non mais c'est les longues
en fait c'est pas là en vrai c'est plus
doux dacquois s il avait continué
poussette ça aurait été cool
après c'est toujours pareil si sam a
émis hier c'était plus qu'une heure
quarante cinq sets jeudi mais c'était
bien c'était vraiment 2h45 2 maintenant
il ya un moment donné c'est long c'est
comme s'il a vraiment sais pas si ça
dure jusqu'à 18h30
ça peut faire un peu moins chaud aussi
le vélo utile de tête à la fin du
tournoi outre chaque match en fait vivre
l'évolution en temps réel mais les lots
officiel édité une fois par mois donc le
1er de chaque mois tu peux savoir
on a appris qu'il peut y avoir des
plugins acteurs des puces caché dans le
hall oreilles époque
et quand tu parles d'oreille oui non
c'est intéressant comme débat et puis il
y avait les gens tu vois il était
construit et c'est un peu comme hier
tuer des gens qui n'étaient pas d'accord
avec moi mais ça me dérange pas parce
que c'était des gens qui veulent
vraiment ils argumenté leurs arguments
étaient intelligents et intelligible et
du coup bah c'était agréable en fait
comme discussions mais c'est vrai que
les jours où les mecs c'est assez normal
que manu jous la world cup parce que
s'ils gagnent pas le match comment il
fait pour faire les candidats y en a dix
qui disent un indice qui sont évidemment
c'est même plus de quoi parlait en fait
mais le règlement est le règlement il
donne des jugements machin donc c'est un
peu relou quand c'est des gens qui
comprennent de quoi il parle il n'y a
pas de problème une question sur un
jeune de saint-erme demandeur sur un
grand ado attiyah si fort ça on va
danser ou pas mal même
dur à dire qui gouverna enfin il a deux
noms on a un trait d'union de doite
c'est un milieu de terrain à ces jeunes
coûte j'espère garder quand même très
con non mais fait officiellement c'est
quand même fort sur quelques problèmes
mais c'est pour ça qu'ils réfléchissent
en fait issu m le tour des trois pour
délicate
un rasheed khan on t'attend jkf 5e et
pas sur f
ça peut jouer en vrai et c'est pour ça
qu'on n'a pas regardé très très con
quand même on va juste trop heureux de
voir tour à trois mois ferme du sart et
faire garder en fait nous restions au
pays
c'est très content dit très content
c'est un méthanomètre hier c'était
vraiment trop drôle quoi ça dans le cas
telle autre
très chaud cours de votre année en fait
c'est encore durer deux heures on voit
une petite nul mais plus intéressante
qui a fait faillir vraiment c'était les
autres donc on aura bien le temps de
parler rien fait toujours un échec
cournon mais je crois que c'est un bon
petit espoir qu'on veut intéressant non
allez la drôme les jours ag2
lalalalalala le
roy j'ai de bons retours c'est un
milliard là nul était vraiment assuré
finale en fait la finale deux tours
c'était exceptionnel
c'est que toutes les défenses marché
s'est montré bon si ça marche aussi si
des fonds comme ça marche aussi
non en fait est juste un truc si les
plombs je veux vraiment le gain ça
pouvait partir dans un truc double
tranchant mais bon il a pas fait quoi
donc c'était nul nul
en fait les deux voulaient pas faire nul
car yakine effet de cfa ce que ne
voulait pas proposer en premier genre il
tient donc de traiter non je ne répète
pas machin et donc du coup ça dure
longtemps points mais oui mais après je
crois que c'est cariat king qui a
vraiment pas fait gaffe qui a un peu
déconné mais en fait non mais karine
vraiment fort
la dent depuis la simpl mars kindy qui
part en angleterre que vous aurez des
clubs d'échecs ça va être ça joue en
angleterre ça dépend d'ailleurs dans
quelle ville tu seras mais londres il ya
plein de choses sacrées dans ce seul jeu
dans toutes les villes du monde en face
en avait partout mais londres il ya
vraiment fait ils ont même une ligue
interne à londres qu'il avait vu les
anglais doit être beaucoup plus
importante que la ligue nationale b
londonien j'adore et je sais mais ne
tient il à arsenal et manchester city et
tottenham everton ont cédé liverpool ça
déserteurs liverpool manchester ils sont
assez proches
londres c'est un peu ils font leurs life
dans leur coin mais alors à londres et à
12000 stan fatah tellement de club est
loin de la mode et du championnat à
londres
et qu'est ce que je veux dire ouais donc
tu vas trouver plein de plein de trucs
en angleterre d'ailleurs la capitale
mondiale des échecs pendant longtemps
elle a oublié tous les tournois genre en
18 min 19 sec
voilà quoi pourquoi tu
très fin des anglais aiment bien ils
sont en bon amateur en quoi ça joue quoi
voilà oxford hockey sur gazon à lyon tu
as plein de clubs à nous-mêmes juste à
côté à mes chansons toutes les grandes
villes de france avec la ben ouais après
tel endroit plus actif que d'autres et
c'est comme ça sourit mes voisins
vendredi d'un club plus ou moins grands
qu'en même temps il y en a plein avec le
débit chapuis dit qu'il preuve d'échec à
londres de monclar en seine et marne
alors je sais pas trop si colas
seine-et-marne à libreville
c'est sûr que oui à lyon il ya un club
arménien je crois sont très très fort
mais c'est possible oui le gestion lyon
déjà c'est un peu liant vania déjà melun
meaux mouiller vos ya eu rejets
polluants son jeu à paris non c'est pas
loin de paris tout ça je sais qu'on te
souviens
la province est bon en fait faut que tu
vois s'il ya des cours
bon pour ton niveau c'était très
débutant à ce que les cours débutants se
passe ta d'ulm h un enfant c'est des
activités s'il ya des gens qui sont là
pour faire des blitz un peu pratiqué
jouer machin tu te sens bien dans
l'ambiance du club aussi ca c'est en
fait personnelle comme démarche mais en
gros qu'est ce que tu as dans un club
que quand tu y va pour jouer tu trouves
des adversaires tu passe un bon moment
que ce soit sympa et que j'avais écrit
et puis là si tu veux des cours qui les
croient adapté pour toi voilà bah tu te
renseignes tu vois prête pas trop des
cours sur internet tu peux prendre un
coach privé cette envie est cerné il ya
quelques gars qui m'ont écrit en mp
meilleur s'était pas très bien passé
dans les clubs dans lesquels ils sont
allés pas de chance non mais ça peut mal
se passer
lens reçoit les mecs m'ont pris 2 au
passé sur internet est touché ce retour
dernière - mais ça ça arrive à pas de
chance tout dans un club ça peut arriver
aussi est allé deux hommes de combat
j'en retiens
et tant pis vous aurez plus qu enfin
pouvoir nous estime si vous êtes mal
reçus et dire votre ressenti et à
d'autres endroits où tu seras bien reçus
seront très heureux de se dire assez
cool on fait des cours les échecs il ya
plus de licencié votre club grandit tu
prends d'autres choses comme ça aussi
donc ça tu as jamais au club de saintes
et non méthylé des histoires
exceptionnelles avec les clubs jamais
racontée dans talent dans ton
département moi je sais pas si c'est le
bon endroit pour en parler mais vérifiez
vos licences ou les avaient pas été
exceptionnel ça c'est des histoires ça
c'est on est sa préférée
tiens je ne vous connais pas plus 40 ans
françois front tu n'es pas vos licences
mas forfait tient sa revanche ce qui
s'est passé dans les interclubs ya pas
de pièces d'identité je ne suis pas bien
sûr que ce soit toi tu toi de faire le
coup pareil dans des derbys au foot
d'où vraiment romain hamouma je ne suis
pas sûr c'est magnifique
hier qui valide le fait que la carte
d'identité enfin t'es pas obligée à la
licence objet de la présente est sûr
c'est que je n'ai jamais jamais jamais
présente mais moi non plus j'ai
jouissance personnes combattent avec ça
mais oui mais bon on en voit même pas
non mais maintenant tout informatisé
mais qui me prouve que tu es bien fabien
lebedev qui en fait n'est ce pas non
mais en vrai ça parce que contrôler les
papiers du coup c'était pas assermentés
par l'état je ne peux pas non on se bat
donc ça non maintenant je dirai comment
quand et en tournage bien sûr je sois
fabien lebedev qui à quel moment on est
sûr en fait c'est jamais sûr j'ai un
pote qui ai fait ça dans un tournoi en
fait il se reconnaître et se reconnaîtra
peut-être mais au bar y avait un gars
c'est ce sens qu'ils performent bien
dans le tournoi et qui prenait le prix
moins de 16 cents et il allait au bar en
trois parties non c'est au minimum un
truc de snack où les mecs boivent des
bières
ouais il a monté la tête à tout le monde
oui ce gars je le connais c'est pas lui
c'est une vague que je vous ai dit
encore gagné en fait j'avais pris un mec
fumoir rondot qui avait vu qu'il est pas
mal après deux rondes je connais je
connais le vrai s'évalue j'ai commencé
je connais il avait monté la dass yoga
dans le bar et après toutes les rondes
il faille continuer à la fin c'est voir
a dit oui ce qui est complètement
voilées seymour et non lui a dit gérard
je suis pas partie prenante de
l'histoire ne fait pas au début des
faits un troll bas juste pour rigoler
c'est prévoir et avec se sont chauffés
du courbât mais à l'alcool il dit non on
peut quand même ton de la plaisanterie
pour les assermentés vous ça va
peut-être mais en fait je trouve ça
injuste le monde c'est vrai que quand tu
fais un chèque de 10 c'était bien toi de
prouver je pense pas qu'il puisse
refuser de présenter des droits de moi
d'aller dans la rue demander l'identité
des gens toi je pense pas marqué ce qui
te donne le pouvoir de bas juste pendant
que comptait la en caisse pour payer ton
truc à te dis ouais enfin touchait que
je poste un volume carnet de chèques
c'est toi qui me dit enfin ils te
demandent chaque fois même double pièce
d'identité maintenant faire et donc ça
c'est vrai mais je ne sais pas mais un
tournoi est ce qu'un arbitre peut faire
ce jeu gens sains en fait dit-il deux
avocats dans cette chute est complexe
c'est marrant comme question puisse
contourner ça quand tu sais vraiment
géré à bien leur en faire chier le monde
allait dans un tournoi je suis à parier
qu'on est hyper connue mais si tu y es
tu je viens de thé pack cmh injures
juste de jouer bien sûr
larbi dit oui je le reconnais ben je ne
te crois pas comble ils peuvent pas
ils peuvent virer du tournoi hockey
après ça toi de voir si ces particules
ne pas présenter ta carte ok donc tu
peux regarder c'est un événement privé
quelque part tu as un truc qui est un
videur à l'entrée qui ne dit rien parce
que bidart me disent que tu as bien 18
ans tu prouves mais c'est intéressant
donc oui donc quand les mecs viennent en
fait au lieu de leur licence ils peuvent
on peut ne doit pouvoir te demander de
produire une pièce d'identité
il faut bien voir sa carte d'identité
avec soin pour jouer ouais moi j'ai
toujours avec moi car d'identité après
mon pote bien sûr j'ai pas par habitude
mais enfin je crois que c'est légal en
fait de l'or surtout en fait c'est jules
permis ou introduit vécu tellement
longtemps en russie où théo obligé
d'avoir ton visa sur toi ou ta carte de
séjour fait là tu es obligé quand
étrangers donc en fait j'ai gardé
l'habitude et ici j'ai tout le temps ma
carte d'identité sur haïti c'est une
obligation jeu ça l'a fait mais je ne
savais pas c'est une évolution pour bien
être sûr que de qui tu es bah on peut
trouver à tout moment faute
parmi les peintres de l'antibois mais
bon ça perd alors si on veut vraiment
chercher c'est beau qu'un fichier coutu
le live is est approprié ou thé penser
que ces missions il va venir et été vos
papiers souplesse complètement interdit
un commissariat je ferai une visée sinon
mes joueurs quant aux etats unis ils
étaient treize logements de ma carte
d'identité et mon père me passait très
bien à pas pour prendre l'avion et dont
j'allais prendre une plateforme
étrangers contrôlent en france je n'ai
jamais sûrement ils me croisent sur
parra en russie ça m'arrivait de pas
l'avoir il te crois pas du tout que tu
dois appeler quelqu'un non non tu
t'amènes au commissariat déjà pour
commencer c'est rappelle les bases pour
le poliment déjà assez case commissariat
direct si t'es pas capable de produire
un deux pièces d'identité
ces retours frontières 1 50 si t'as pas
ton visa ces retours frontières instant
tu sais tu as pas d'enregistrement dans
la ville ce qui est obligatoire
c'est le nom ça peut être retour
frontières c'est peut être tour
frontières ils ont failli brian joubert
a failli se prendre le retour frontière
quand il est à moscou au projet parce
qu'il faisait une fois ci en dessous il
avait pas ça il essaie il a fini au
commissariat et où il patinait d'appât
sont rués sur lui mais il n'avait pas le
truc de l'autre elle est là en fait tu
te met en relation avec l'hôtel où avec
l'ambassade qui s'explique quoi faire
mais si tu es incapable de prouver qu'il
y ait quelque part étudier pas dans la
rue ce qui est interdit c'est retour
frontières aussi donc là tu peux te
rendre du retour frontières dans la
gueule toi donc j'ai vraiment hâte les
papiers avec toi mais du coup a été
obligé en russie sont vraiment pas sympa
il te croit jamais non ils sont toujours
très très chaud pour se méfier en fait
où il y eut comme ça d'autres un agent
non non pas du tout c'est juste comme ça
enfin trouvé ses papiers tu dégages mais
non enfin je sais pas ce qu'on peut
faire c'est à pas les papiers va j'ai
jamais le problème
cheikh était censé avoir juste pour par
la casse car yakine unités et
universités les plus neutres au square
c'est vrai mais s'est depuis séparé là
on l'espère un petit des 6 et d'hommes
pranger deux ont pas de chance il a vu
il défend donc il veut concéder puntos à
fond même g5 s'est changé d'âme
et puis abandonnée car si on a pu se
passer c'est ça on pousse un coup je
t'échange lieu de je te pousse bref pas
jusque là toujours est il qu'à yaguine
candidat c'est fait et finaliste
accessoirement mais non bah bravo à lui
et donc la seule partie du jour qui
continue de jouer c'est celle ci nous
dans petite sueur
il a fait au moins huit et chaque projet
c'est de tempo la cam en fait le roi g7
mais a dû beaucoup réfléchi après ce
tempo cavalier e 5 6 3
l'estrie glissé nul non ouais mais bon
on s'attend une mieux mais pas fait quoi
le moyen peut-être de faire un peu des
conneries ici ou là ouais bah du coup
bravo karekin ans quand même maintenant
voilà qui fait un retour au premier plan
mais qui en plus a fait un très bon
tournoi bien maîtrisé toujours solide et
bien broc mais comme je dresse fait
plutôt plaisir de voir un joueur comme
lui qui aux candidats c'est un peu la
place qu'il est censé occuper quoi ouais
donc bon c'est bien pour lui en vrai car
yakine sera vu en finale d'une coupe du
monde d'échecs sans jouer un top 10
reste avec maxime est un peu baissé mais
ça fait papier défunt quand tu te rends
maxime sur ta route c'est pas super au
matin pendant quoi de la ville et pato
de 10 actuellement tournée d'accord j'ai
réussi ma mission finale n'ont pu y aura
pas jointe un vice caché ça c'est quand
même le tennis est rare de jouer et un
climat finalistes jouent 0 top top 10
reste avec feydeau cfa2 me battais
comptant dans le monde un tournant on te
dit ça tu dis bon bah ouais ça fait
plaisir
shanklin encartés comptons aussi
vraiment sur le papier un jeudi après
c'est vraiment mais bon il a quand même
eu arthémy h autour d' avance pas
évident en fait d'apple un tableau fait
c'est un début de tableau difficile une
fin de tableau face aux versions la fête
artemiev mvele seller beaucoup plus fort
a tué la tension at war et demi
parce que les tops ont été linutop en
fait les tops fort dans ce format donc
ding il jouait pas née peau et radjabov
il a gagné le dernier mais il jouait pas
ça et à rognan est malade donc les
quatre top-10 fort il n'était pas là
après il ya un reggae risso ouest rue
pas notion non en fait il manque en fait
ce que disait il manque une dimension
numéro 2 3 4 5 et 6 due forme tabanac
alors n'accueille pas si bon ce format
en général et s'il se chauffe mais
toujours dangereux d'un cas il peut
juste faire deux turbos d'euros comme ça
est toujours rapide à sainte maxime et
cardiaques avait un peu hein mais c'est
pour ça que mon match voilà une est
morte devant lequel nous faisons là
après évidemment tu as pas gagné
d'avancé ont défait de ses gaffes et des
chants clamé des favoris quoi alors
quand tu fais cet affrontement ankara
qui de maxime tu te dis bah c'est le
champion à duda il va avoir joué à faire
la cigale pour aller en finale il aura
joué gris tchouk le petit visite j deal
et ses gros quoi je crois que même avant
il n'a pas eu un truc aussi facile que
ça chez plus sombre et plus ont par
contre pu en tête mais après dans les
oueds hongrie choot qui est bon est au
format
bon après il est tombé sur duda mais lui
c'est un des bons dans ce format mais je
trouve pas qu'il soit régulier pour ce
faire main basse il est chaud il est
chauve mais comment fait c'est un joueur
un peu de rush me levant perte de temps
en temps pour tous regagné en fait c'est
plus un format ou c'est bien ne jamais
perdre et c'est pas tellement style
mamie quoi est guéri il performe pas
signant ses formes a pourtant ça
pourrait être un truc pour lui sont pas
vides il est jamais si loin dans le
consul trop peut-être qui suent trop je
sais pas un bail issue
enfin en tout cas car yakine ses mérites
fin c'est vrai c'est mérité 1 sur le
tronc il a vraiment bien joué un rôle
qui devrait très bien
angers on nettoie jeu monsieur faire
l'analyse demande
à mathieu carrenet
le 12 heures du coup ouais bah oui ou
non le carnac gars qui a rien à dire
c'est très bien que tu fais mais c'était
écrasement quoi voiture est celle de
madagascar et c'est beau mais enfin
c'est vos copains qui de par plus trésor
de rester jusqu'à demain quoi s oui ils
continuent d'attaquer stand était bien
la vidéo mais j'ai su recommandé depuis
hier dans le live mais bizarrement enfin
le plus de vues du coup quand à
recompter ou pour passer une bonne vidéo
c'est une grosse système d' attaque le
plan avec le roi h et un tour junte ça
c'était assez cool bien de connaître ces
des échecs qui a émigré tube do
d'ajustement du nu dans les rapides il
l'avait battue tu peux rester un deux
ans 8 août
moi ça me dérange pas et vous aussi
réfléchi pendant 6,6 pour cent vers
mayotte thesis battue reste là tu es
bien loin tu repars enfin
et encore jeanne qui rit mais non faut y
fait n'est pas très vieux mais ça répond
par rapport à quoi ça fait longtemps
qu'on voit quand même aussi ça arrive
6 qu'est ce que je faisais en russie
pendant dix ans je vivais là mais en
vrai oui puisque dix ans c'est long oui
mais tu habites à tuer ta life
ouais je ne m'en a inventé pas ça c'est
important
un peu ouais c'est pas si nul nul assez
nul nul mais les conneries perdu mais
quand les gars du retour à quatre ça
un jeu à part exigé que j'ai fait un
film est plein de gens différents fête
du goût de rouille et donc oui et non
j'ai fait part à pois j'ai fait en
rapport avec les échecs j'ai fait pas en
rapport avec les échecs je fais plein de
choses différentes
c'est qui qui est du bon côté de la
nulle la bombe personnes en fait enfin
c'est gérard meauxsoone bas sur cette
aucun des deux peut-être ses chances
égales de faire une connerie mais j'y
arrive c'est vraiment nul nul quand même
enfin on espère voir disparition des
combats et des matrix est venu et a le
vent qui se lève un peu comme hier donc
une petite brise c'est bien ça fais umba
café ou en ce moment où pas moyen je
pense avait plus sensibles à votre cas
qu cadeau de vidalia moi aussi je le
sens plus comme ça aujourd'hui mais je
préfère le zumba café ou quand même
après café au carnaval un bond de 4,4
tintin aux bords sont pistés par la
banale 1
le rajout danse à deux coups selon les
parties entre moment où ta date est
moins que des plus trop de temps d'y
jouer tampon c3 fait de cette fête des
coûts que j'aime cet échec un petit truc
comment détruire l'intérêt pour les
échecs en quelques mois le final pour ce
qu'un des bonnes questions quoi faisant
café sepa sepa bolchoï a des bons débats
mais oui mais moi j longue il faut ici
charge en retour de sûr c'est 3 g 8 en
fin septembre jal peut faire tour de le
temps passe et 3 à vrai dire on est au
recentrage utiliseront ces six mois
malheureusement d'accord le tropicaux du
pakistan mais mais c'est en fait on en a
marre des échecs lâche quand vont
essayer de jouer alléluia qui revient
bien mais il marche bien et duda son
retour au classement il ya encore
quelques jours de compet tours sète il
se met en face du pionnier statique loi
font tarifs
une gamme intéressante ouais j'ai encore
un eto'o va tout analyser la défoncer je
passe ma déjà répondu ainsi à un moment
de vie dont on pourra juste regardé vite
faire sa partie en cliquant et la bombe
a brandi un peu quelque chose de jouer
deux coups d'affilée donc cinq minutes
40 pour magnus
oui ça ce qui va jouer mais réfléchis un
peu mais c'est les blancs fait qu'ils
peuvent faire c'est en fait s'il fait
autour des 1 admettons fait tout ça est
très bref quatre ans est 5ème et c5 prix
inquiète sûrement bon bah c'est
complètement nul mais j'étais à jouer
comme non j'espère qu'à qui me tourner
cavalli pions oui mais j'ai assez plutôt
les phares et les blancs peuvent
absolument affaire d'état estime une
fourchette
on s'est complètement de la mer d'un
mets pas ça peut jouer longtemps c'est
en fait non toi si tu vas partir de 18
heures à 17h45
non monsieur 18h30 pour être jouable
sympa nous verrons le voyage tous âges
aux mines chapeauté d un vin était très
heureuse de nouvelles m'apporter son
joue à fond la carte si l'on voit sur la
tête pour me réveiller regarde j'ai déjà
avec la corde
je suis toujours dit qu'on mesure où un
peu vite je vois le top 12 en fin juin
depuis j'ai pas joué j'ai joué par
équipes ans en septembre
donc ça a toujours lieu tout ça en fait
je devais faire sans attendre
pajtim déjà aux canaries mais ils ont
annulée par crainte qu'ils aient des
restrictions qu'ils aient pas la salle
tout ça et finalement y'a rien vu donc
ça aurait pu avoir lieu
mon père a pas lâché l'info ce matin il
y croit mais il y croit je sais pas
enfin il a aucun rapport
non non il en sait rien et que je veux
dire et du coup ils vont se tourner un
peu lieu soit fait des vacances aux
canaries puis voilà peut-être même mieux
placé au dessus non mais sinon halte au
maintien oui j'ai prié de le faire de
base après je t'ai pas sûr d'être
vraiment libre motifs personnels et donc
j'ai préféré prévenir les ordinateurs
dire ouais c'est possible que je suis
pas jouer du coup pour finir peut-être
pour inviter quelqu'un d'autre et c'est
et il se trouve qu'au final j'ai pu être
libre à ces dates-là donc ce coup une
bonne nouvelle pour moi mais
je préfère me désinscrire une partie
d'échecs la plus longue avec 269 coup hu
s'est terminée par en partie du g20 pour
lutter en archi profit leurs affaires
d'une quand même
par exemple chez richard boudreault
voilà quoi enfin 7 3 les affaires tour
ses sept
mais il est quand même mieux avec les
bans et les blancs qui pressent un
presse la découverte est beaucoup plus
tard sa première mutu ne disent les
coûts n'ont pas de problème a enfin
battu je suis côté blanc va tu fus rien
du tout mais quand on a perdu 10 kg à
tous on ne va rien n'avait sa sanction
des c5 qui vient fond mais je crois que
j'ai fait un truc très court en fait non
mais même là quand elle voulait tour un
tour machin comme en effet on a fait un
nul
il prend même cavalli son full attack
délicate prince a dit prendre quatre
ouais c'est vrai que torride toros
attaque aime bien jouer on n'était pas
bien vrai et jaffe tour 8 avant de jouer
après l'arrivée dans la même truc mais
refait chaque fois on nous on avait été
trop gourmand et va faire tour des
seuils kg qu'attache 4h 5h 6 qui avait
600 votes
j'ai pas vrai dire c'est pas si simple
non non aussi petite poussette double
enrichir et une au tessin russe préfère
les chiens oshana il préfère les chats
les russes sont plus ça on n'en dit rien
je les sens comme ça ce n'est ni son
chat moi je suis plus chiant mais bon ça
va le changer un contrôle matt avait
quand même sultan tu avais eu j'aurais
contrôle désormais enfin j'en ai eu dans
ma vie quand même mon chien quand même
même bien le rapport
[Musique]
mais sont sympas ils sont contents une
fidélité ils ont des bonnes valeurs
le chat il fait ça là il s'en fout de
toi en fait fin même s'il est sympa dans
le fond tu comprends qu'il peut tenir
quoi il s'en fout complètement même
taille
le chien il t'aime bien enfin où il fait
semblant mais deux en argent que tu
aimes bien intriguant et amiens je vous
aime bien mais ballon temps qu'enfin
razoux je crois qu'ils s'intéressent à
plein de trucs fait ses pairs très vite
sa concentration le chien j'en suis très
vite à quoi il ya des fulgurances
parfois très content bien sûr venus
williams a pas de là bas une mouche qui
est passé de klaxons gens dans la rue
car j'entends un chien aboyer de très
loin je dois aller surveiller la porte
mischa dans le chat est fait vraiment
cette tête en plus un peu le profil un
peu regarde comme un pigeon
charest de concentration 50 hyper actif
de 5 ans et un pcf fasse trop de trucs
en fait on a un mur d'eau michaud qui
prend forme
je n'aime pas on ne croit pas mais je
veux bien le croire c'est en fait tu
fonces alem tout le monde n'en voit plus
mais bon après et mais c'est tellement
un métro humains en fait j'ai peut-être
qu'ils aimaient leurs seins la vidéo là
que je voudrais sur le média pro natif
booster une nana qui a perdu son chien
vont pas de chance aux états unis vont
là elle se décide finalement au bout de
deux ans un rat refuge pour ben vas-y je
vais adopter un autre quoi et chance
elle retrouve sur le même quoi et là il
ya les retrouvailles boucher les trous
d'eau il vraiment content quoi deux ans
tu vas faire il l'a pas oubliée il fait
la fête à fond et je vois tout chance je
vous dis bonne crème il aime bien
qu'enfin même le jour qu'on est ensemble
que nous rester avec l'ina en ville et
que je suis va tu peux rentrer avec le
chien s'était pas pu rentrer mais voilà
elle veut absolument pas je veux rester
avec eux deux c'est d'autres non
je pense qu'en fait le chien ils pensent
plus en eux tout est maintenant un but
de luca moi ça joue
plus intéressant qui a carrément je peux
dire c'est vraiment j'ai longtemps ça
peut jouer longtemps ça
il faut chasser plus intéressant est
tout aussi affectueux nan mais c'est
vrai ça dépend des chasses dépend des
chiens ce que cette chasse comme nature
et découvertes la demande maillot rose
cette nature et découvrit alors
intéressant quoi points comme quand même
temps comme point fr un point comme ça
chez fran s achever non mais attends qu
ils s'envoient des coups on attend que
ça clique manet et pousse ses pions là
un pion l'avoir une tour en soutien
le cheval qui débarque là attention
mais on voit des stats dans le chat ne
nous aiment pas la source sur socket un
chien crois moi
c'est complexe mais les russes avec des
numéros de cirque avec les chaluts sinon
ouais il ya un cirque de chats moscou à
ce jour plus de respect parce que c'est
très dur et ils en sont très fiers en
fait en russie ça existe ces paysages et
ils ont en fait nulle part ailleurs
complètement
le chien se fait 122 noyer il en pls
aussi je pense le chan vient pas du tout
800 chaînes en place il ya le chalet à
fond avec le ch est très concentré dans
l'eau je savais à mon papa n'était pas
un bon choix pour pas savoir ça
à
c'est pas financer cinq ici seuls blancs
de jouer c'est sûr 1 tour 17
ouais ou h4 ou un coup maxime s'est fait
éliminer par le jour le plus fort de sa
partie de tableau clairement même
c'était vraiment les deux plus forts ils
se sont vus jouer en huitièmes est et
les deux plus forts 9
bon bah écoute c'est long il faut
cliquer là bang bang à quoi faisait
beaucoup tellement le débat chiens chats
font cette histoire de shibam c'est un
grand chiba un axe tard au japon
ben oui mais qu'ils allaient voir sans
jamais enfin oui miche en parle des
[ __ ] c'est beau il est allongé et ça
y est je suis en fait c'est pragmatique
avec michel c'est dexia qui tue et qui
s'approche soit sa maison soit sa taille
qui jusqu'à elle est hyper agressive
après ça excitait une maison quoi pense
que michel on serait très heureux
elle défend bien je veux dire partout je
ne sais pas comme les chiens qui dorment
et qui s'en foutra elle tient lui
s'approcher et puis c'est pas par peur
en fait tu veux penser des petits chiens
et sa voix par peur en fait elle aboie
mais pour aller se taper c'est terrible
chico le chien mais bien mija qu'elle
donne son avis quoi en fait sur les
chiens et chats vous ordonnez x pert je
sais pas ce qu'elle est très belle et
très nerveuse genre est une pure on ne
bat p 1308 sur chaise comme effet pas
qu'ils jouaient sur de chasse comme mais
possible ya plein de joueurs l'équipe de
france de foot qui joue je viens de
comano mais chemin qu'il veut pas mal
quand même
ouais ouais on va les captures en
grandissant avec c'est une pression pas
mal aussi la vue 308 mbp quoi
la voix qui seule femme
[Musique]
bon well com'n 15 cents lots c'est bon
en 15/100 rapide ouais tu as comme au
bout il faut déjà avoir pas mal joué
ouais ça me fais du sport je suis en
bons kamba paix serait bon qu'ils disent
les échecs et le tennis construit comme
ça le faisait sauter dessus
ça a l'air de se faire chier c'est beau
mais heureusement il ya par ajout de ouf
c'est deux fois trente minutes c'est
encore une heure mais en fait ça doit
être ça attendez 5-2 kg 4 h 5 et 6 roi
ici qui est prend h5 forcé de en fait ça
qui va le faire chier et tu te tapes f2
lorsqu'elle chaud moi je crois j'ai pas
été simple mais j'ai en fait il doit
vouloir essayer de gagner h son père def
du complexe manson qui nettoie dans sa
table qu'est ce que je suis en santé
cette nature des 2 kg 4
si complexe mais attention cette fuite
est redoublée t2 à faire le fameux h5
est tout simple et turf est là ça
ressemble beaucoup
vous savez autant on va tous et c'est
pourquoi je fais quatre sk session
danila medvedev numéro 2 mondial de
tennis et 1780 sur deux chaises comme
mais mettez les liens des comptes un
poil et nos fins possibles avec moi des
affiches aux forces qui les rousses cov
même en fait dans des fonds du copier
coller d'un truc ouais une sorte de
bottes qui donne des infos mais je sais
pas d'où photo cas il a aussi tout
repenser 6 du coup c'est plus pour faire
un nul gérer non mais ça joue mais non
mais en fait je te dis que ce 0 0
c'est pas par tous genres c'est évident
on tue niveau vous lloris et 0 0 c'est
pourquoi j'ai su que ça j'aurai je
pensais que je fais un super match
d'hier je perds un de prime abord mais
je jouerai mais moi je pensais je
penserai que
on va attendre la fin du compte à
rebours alors il y aura 1 30 minutes de
plus un qui va qui va tomber dans quatre
co c'est incroyable s'y ajoutent à cames
élimine nous faudra revoir notre
jugement sur le tour vraiment un coup de
génie en fait ouais il m'a parlé il m'a
vraiment fait forte impression tout ça
quand même
aïe presse puis il a bien fait aussi qui
domine un peu dans ce match pour
l'instant ça va jouer là je pense va
faire tour d2 il va y avoir un petit peu
prendre du cavalier en c6 est pur il va
y avoir assez de temps jusqu'au 40e coup
au bras largement enfin ces quatre coups
à jouer en 2 minutes ont réussi à faire
un tout une partagent 5 donnes tu crois
pas à vrai dire
mais ça revient jouer fait ya tellement
de possibilités pour les deux tours
surtout le trop plein de coups alors qui
des sages continue peut-être peut faire
annuler l'épreuve absolument nulle moi
je vais coucher parce qu'au moins demain
c'est bien nul toi qui as et 17 pour qui
ces secteurs prince edward kitsis quoi
ouais mais je le dis sur wave 7 nous
sortir de là à merveille ses 500 reprend
oui tu as aussi caillassé partageront
les deux idées mongai fils est plus fine
mais gère ta lettre tu as une double
menace
en fait les gens se questionnent sans
classement de même veine au tennis mais
il n'est pas classé très dangereux je
réglais il ya un revers étonnant que tu
sais pas trop mais paiva pas facile à
lire son revers tu sais pas tu peux
patron d'ibm quoi anticiper pour demain
pascal sur des cinq pour des deux
sûrement françois pas de si grave
je suis un peu comme chez puisque tu
parlais
on a sûrement un truc là ça je sais pas
ce que ça donne
complexe non ouais
bref 5 ce que le froid chaque épouse sa
finale de carlson complexe mais mon idée
alors plein de mer dû faire mieux pour
carlson mais en fait c'est sa déposition
nul mais où tu peux jouer pour que
pendant trente quarante cinquante cool
et blanc risque jamais de perdre et où
tu peux te faire planter une fourchette
ou un truc un monde les a crus cavaliers
c'est toujours dangereux gens qui
avancent et un peu machin tu peux tu
peux te la perdre
le kf six bons rails fut de tempo on
croit je suis trois tableaux
je suis arrêté tour h7 matt presse et
une belle partie 1 tour 17
pour juste pour dire si vous avez faire
nul c'est toujours ça fait nul est juste
un petit schéma quoi jeu d échec partout
en europe jamais l'autre côté puisqu'il
émane donc il doit rester sur les
colonnes en qualifs et les échappements
bon allez on va pas faire a priori
baissé de 3,5 et je veux bien
il forçait un peu grâce à défendre mais
c'est un petit peu terne qui peut être
sympa à connaître dans 17 et le cavalier
fait c est chacun
ce sera si tu proposes neil robinson va
la jouer un petit peu quand même mathieu
oui mais bon nul à 17h35 ce serait quand
même dommage pas pourquoi pas faire nul
à 19 heures on est bien là trop détendu
femme qui va finir par rester ici ce
soir encore je bouge un 18 ans pas de
chance c'est bon quoi plus raide
manon mais pour en mettre quoi vraiment
je me fais pas défoncer son espace rien
il a pris h5
c'est humain contre humain
ces tournois
moi je préfère jouer pleinement ce truc
bah oui c'est sûr de l'ong mercy corps
go mais a pris à un dégât ni la kalach
il est heureux de tout garder une pépite
des abonnés de chess comme sur le site
il ya une petite série vidéo qui peut
compléter en plus facile quoi est ce que
tu as déjà pensé faire un cours sur la
calèche chercher sable non jamais non
c'est pas possible c'est beaucoup sur
chez sable j'étais très heureuse hirsch
et ça me fait marrer de dire chez sable
ses talons plus beau quand l'anglais oui
c'est nul c'est complexe moi c'est
complexe
a priori nul 1 1 ce qui coûte les ordis
22 00 partout mais peu trompé quand on a
mais c'est sûr que c'est un jeu ça
devrait continuer de regarder mais je ne
ferai suez mais je pense qu à leur
niveau ils suis pas sûr qu'il ya quatre
ans cette part va marcher dans tous les
sens la mecap scène il a joué un coup il
est parti marie du parti je pense sans
sens c'est interdit sa pop ta parlant de
te lever sur ton temps en fait en tout
cas c'était comme ça avant seul arbitre
si c'est le cas dans ces qualifications
immédiate à ce qualificatif
enfin l'option de pierluigi collina la
non mais ça moi on m'a déjà dit fin
arbitres pas déjà fait la remontrance tu
joues après tu vos toilettes en fait tu
peux pas aller sur ton temps mais
peut-être règles à changer ça c'était un
truc c puis c'est un arbitre de national
troyes ou de chelsea n'ont pas tous
remercient bidon ou en vélo
et on avait dit que tu pouvais pas que
tu peux pas le faire après naturel
d'être l'arbitré à l'époque s'étaient
trompés c'est possible et peut-être que
les règles ont changé mais sinon c'est
très étonnant qu'ils aient pas une
intervention arbitrale on va demander
dans le chatt ya des arbitres si on a le
droit de se lever sur son temps de la
différence entre se balader le mec joue
tu t'emballes grondement touche de balle
allait être là à voir qui jouera dire je
me casse ça c'est différent c'est
pourtant on a le droit ou pas de faire
ça chez moi on m'a déjà fait la
remontrance est joseba stop à rome est
pour moi tu vas pas faire un truc mais
bon prêt pass belle dit oui on a alors
arrêté arbitres coupat fonction
entourage une personne qui s'appelle je
me lève je t'emmerde cloud pour preuve
un doute une barque
ouais je n'aime pas voir qu'il a fait
rouler je n'ai pas vu je n'ai pas vu aux
règles et aux risques pour ça je demande
ce que des règles ont pu changer ou moi
je suis tombé sur un arbitre qui
connaissaient pas bien la règle présent
tu restes assis au vote mais dit tu
joues ton cou après tu te lèves je vois
mon coup je me suis levé 20 oui mais du
coup si c'était près très près ces
artistes-là sur les 41 - l'alliance
passée c'est au lard et c'est cissé
et johnny mais attention si on
n'existait pas légal ces passe-droits et
légale illégale après au méga sais pas
quoi je termine seulement clément sur le
temps tu peux aller tricher aux
toilettes
bavay de lazovic pénalisable automne oui
mais bon c'est interdit enfin c'est pas
la question c'est soit c'est illégal
c'est illégal
j'ai envie de te dis que c'est possible
mais ça peut changer ça peut être
possible c'est pour ça que je demande ça
serait l'inversé avec le trait il a
réfléchi un peu puis il s'est levé je
suis allé voir l'arbitré car pour moi ce
n'était pas normal halimi du 40e après
déjà éclaté alors par habitude ou hip
hop quoi j'ai du coup j'ai dit que leur
vie ne serait pas mon adversaire allumer
son téléphone
j'ai souvent pensé qu'un outil je pense
tu n'as pas le droit de rentrer au
vestiaire pendant un après un point
pendant un jeu où quoi tu dois t'en de
la fin de ton est alors qu'il a envie d
aller aux toilettes c'est un peu une
blague non mais fiber oui non en fait
ils ont un rajout lé mais revient c'est
juste mathieu qui va nous demander parce
que pour lui aussi tu as été légal mais
ça a un peu changé au contraire par non
or 0 il n'a pas pris en compte le rajout
du 40e pas d'affolement
oui mais bon pour le coup de chaud qu il
attend la fin des sept
c'est pareil machin ou quoi mais jaillit
bail à 15 0 mais sorti leurs besoins le
droit tant qu'ils restent dans la salle
en gros je pense c'est légal mais pas
fair-play donc ça ne se fait pas quelque
chose pas fair-play un présent la salle
mais il est parti de la salle
enfin la zone de jeu ok tu peux même
aller au bar sis et consternation de je
ne sais pas ça pour voir c'est peut-être
changer parce que tu ailles avons ici je
parle d'un truc c'est à peut-être 25 en
coiffant 20 ans 22 ans 23 ans un dicton
qui on le sait ok on l'a vu rester et
pai a dû aller aux toilettes ou chercher
un truc à boire ou à manger pour pour
éviter la fringale
je commence à me paraît pas du tout fair
play non plus mais presse parce qu'on
nous apprendre à nous lever quand ça
nous de jouer donc c'est un flocon
peut-être certains biais cognitifs
non mais tu te dis ouais le mal que tu
va discuter travail la personne qui
discutent et un pour le coup c'est
encore un cadre de différentes dans un
open
on va taper avec le mec puisse parler de
quelqu'un pendant que ça fait de jouer
et que j'y tiens je t'ai le coup fais ci
fais ça tu as pas à parler jamais en
fait mais c'est à toi de jouer était
ainsi tu réfléchis tu joues en fait est
là pour le coup oui évidemment et la
personne avec qui elle discute et donc
après il veut faire un truc qui peut
aider c'est d'aller voir les parties sur
l'échiquier en 2d mais bon peut-être là
il peut déjà le voir netone défense il
voit pas mais non mais après là il n'a
rien fait enfin bon peu importe
moi je veux juste avant le règlement
après c'était interdit c'est interdit la
série b à ba oui c'est les gars c'est
légal un légal illégal mais c'est légal
tout à fait le droit après qu'un mois
une fois j'avais raconté qu'il avait
défoncé tibia j'allais mettre des trucs
qui avait rien de larbitre arbitres
avait dit ça joue hier je vous demande à
quel point tu as le droit de décider des
mac vous de péter la gueule juillet
avant la partie ils m'ont dit que
t'avais pas le droit de s'en prendre
physiquement l'adversaire on est en fait
le problème du team bien c'est que ça
peut être vu comme un truc il n'y a pas
fait exprès c'est pour ça que c'était
prix l'a pas fait exprès mais bon
j'avais comme un hématome au tibia quoi
un moment donné tu as que six mois j'en
mets en fait toute façon des échecs
mission votre vie du sujet avait-il dit
rien de façon ça se sait c'est un petit
milieu puis après tu préfères mans s'est
fait chair c'est pas normal fois j'avais
quand même 11 ans ou 12 ans tu as le
gars il est adulte enfin j'avais
vraiment un vrai macho me coiffe c'était
pareil hein c'était juste et ma façon
mais bien de salémata le film qui l'a
fait exprès notre défense on n'a pas
fait exprès mais bon j'ai perdu en 20
minutes ce que j'avais trop mal et enfin
du coup je comprends que ça mais c'est
comme au rugby maintenant
enfin j'ai maté un truc que tu contactes
en larmes et qu'on peut retomber sur la
tête fait tu t'en fous que soit
volontaire ou pas c'est juste à
pénaliser le gars en face j'aurais
d'autres martin au pied
ouais mais c'est saint martin sa défense
il m'a défoncé et en fait juste ça se
voit que fins était égal et j'ai perdu
en 20min fois j'avais trop mal en fait
1 j'avais pas si je m'étais pas casser
quelque chose ou pas je sais pas en fait
j'étais en sueur et volontaire ou pas
bon tu dois prendre forfait c'est pas
grave du tendon sus compagnie rien de
chance mais bon vous prouver que tu as
bien fait les maths aux deux mâles allez
madame c'était visible non pas le mec
avant le thème du jour des bateaux
mouches avaient fait un gros bruit dans
la salle et gaster tourner ça se voyait
qu'eux mais c'est vrai que je mens dsk
la rigueur les mecs se lève ou coup de
genou sur le coccyx efficace le dos tu
le paralyse un peu plus joué au monde
pourquoi pas tous rage 2 bat fait six
ans qu'on va perdre en mais en fait tu
attires le roi ici en fait les bleuets
sont bienvenues de monter ce roi qui
soutiennent les pions lequel viennent la
clé puis on avance donc en gros s'ils
vont font ça c'est plutôt dans le sens
de ce qu'ils veulent faire dans les
prochains coups alors que nous avons
attaqué ça ou c'est de faire des
échanges réduire le matériel et c'est à
notre tour ajoute toujours un coût un
peu inutile en soi et je suis allé un
coup un peu utile sûrement pas suffisant
pour perdre
enfin je sais pas mais faire échec pour
faire échec
on commence pas trop article 12 6 il est
interdit de distraire de déranger
adverse avec quelques mers que ce soit
ceux ci incluent les demandes justifiées
les offres de logiciels ou
l'introduction d'une source bruit dans
la zone de jéhovah mais taper sur la
gueule
mais si c'est justifié sa wallemme bakou
y avait là m'a vraiment en l'occurrence
dans mon cas de figure je pense que fait
un forfait était normal quoi
bref cette
bon faut sûrement faire 308 wayne ne pas
échanger
ce que j'ai déjà eu un mais qui se cure
le nez pendant toute la partie web
albums j'ai des ports quoi très chiant
on y faire il vaut mieux ne pas trop
faire gaffe enfin tu joue juste de
chaque avec les pièces que tu as devant
toi tu reviens pas ok en fait il va
échanger à ses convives et faire tourner
ses huîtres cette montée non je veux
dire juste sur des singles jouer ça mais
c'est en fait je pensais que ça pouvait
être perdants parce que le roi est loin
mais il a dû calculer ça va être drôle
il reviendrait mais je vais peut-être
qu'il y avait 4 h 5 h si simon slowey un
message est rempli de par exemple tu
sujet est rafraîchie bien ouais bon à
vrai dire tu peux penser que ses paires
l'ansa non mais moi je serai pas méga
confortable j'oserais de vue quoi
précise jean phi je vois vous je bloque
un chat n'y a pas de problème mais juste
devise us
est-ce que je n'avais pas prime quand
j'ai fait montre et c'est tombé le mec
autant montrant sa pendule non non
c'était bien passé mis à willer vita
côté-là rien dit ça m'embête c'est en
fait une toute une période je me suis
fait enfler par l'arbitrage donc j'irai
jusqu'à ce que j'ai 15 ans où il
m'arrivait de plein de faim je
répondrais les pieds sous chez pias a
joué pas fait manu des hypers honnête
même genre enfin hyper fair play et tout
est à force de me faire entuber un
régime à des arbitres sont nulles et du
coup j'ai fait ça j'ai fait appuyer
faire tomber la pendule autant de
l'adversaire
je sais comment ça fait trop de trucs
comme ça mais je fais trop fait enfler
du coup j'ai commencé à faire dans
l'autre sens après j'ai refusé de
l'argent pour me laisser gagner une
partie dans un tournoi en fait j'ai rien
fait qui soit pas visible par les
arbitres savent que à chaque fois que
j'ai fait ces choses là il y avait un
arbitre juste à côté quand j'ai fait
tomber la pendue pour gagner du temps
l'arbitré tester revient à parfaire
verte était vraiment à un mètre de moi
et regarder que notre parti quand j'ai
montré le temps que la personne n'était
pas tombé l'arbite était aussi juste à
côté
j'espère que j'ai jamais honnêtement
j'ai jamais fait un truc salle sans une
présence d'un arbitre très proches mais
en fait vu que vous faites rien que vous
êtes nuls etc ou servent à rien bah
enfin un temps qui passe non mais fait
je pars du principe que c'est des plots
et que bah oui mais bon s'agit pas elle
habite à côté des adversaires ils s'en
foutent
zeego m weiner il s'en foutait nez de
frazer faisait deux trucs que j'ai fait
les adversaires s'en foutent et envahie
de trucs quand je fais tomber la pendule
j'étais déjà gagnant donc face à manger
et quand j'ai montré la pendue j'étais
aussi gagnant juste à me faisait chier
de transformer le truc fire plus vite
non mais en fait j'ai l'équivalent d'un
truc comme ça mais comme si j'avais
encore des pions et 3 f2 avec les blancs
moi et que j'ai le ranger 2 qui avait
quatre c'est que je pousse les cons ça
me faisait chier de transport des trucs
dedans mais ça faisait chier quand à lui
commander plonge d'abord c'est
abandonner
fauqué au moins ça termine le truc avec
la pendule
ouais c'est un peu plus chaud
l'adversaire a commencé à faire
n'importe quoi en fait pas c'est lui qui
a commencé pour la peine et leur habitat
rien 17 heures qu'il a joint un coup il
a fait tomber un truc
ouais surmontant temps est notre un peu
oui à rester unique 30 chacun c'était le
troisième avec notes ça tarde donc le
mec me fout un coup et une pièce par
terre il appuie sur la pendule leur
place je dire place tapia si la personne
qui dit rien il leur fait la deuxième
fois j'ai appuyé sur son banc j'ai foutu
la pendule parterre évasive la porte sur
ton tona rck
mais ok mais là je comprends mieux mais
c'est un long historique avant oui mais
bon je vais quand même fait ça et
eiffage étaient insupportables en tout
cru qu'après et le mec a quitté le
tournoi de ronde après été dégoûté mais
en fait juste il a commencé à faire le
truc une fois c'est un fétiche capendu
par terre comme tamsir hamas mais bien
sûr tout le temps quand même et j'appuie
super fort pour lancer hyper fort le
chrono à un drapeau oui oui avec force à
veut bien faire tomber une fois ouais
j'ai appuyé fort il a piégé rappuyer
quand même juste j'y arrive de plus sur
le doigt peut pas excuser un appui en
fait j'ai fait que des trucs dégueu mais
je t'ai gagnera la pollution mais bon
c'est juste il m'a fait tilt ça m'a
énervé je suis matière tous les trucs
dégueulasses que je connais à vendre
relancé hier sur ton temps ce n'est pas
facile hiromichi à l'entrée afin d'être
à sa fille avait deux monnaies bah oui
bah il devait être là mais j'étais
gagnant quand même puisque j'étais
complètement gagnant
j'ai fait aussi j'ai fait des trucs
dégâts mais je me suis fait enfler avant
j'ai fait mes valises c'est génial par
contre ce truc
il a fait il aurait utilisé contre glay